Das war's für heute.
American Hero, mein Sohn.
So Leute.
da bin ich am start ist echt noch viel zu viel und das obwohl ich schon
irgendwie eine stunde auf bin das ist ja gar nicht so dass ich gerade eben das
aufgemacht habe ich finde ich müde alles passt ja ist ja aufwachen stream
ja auch ich muss den chat refreshen ich sehe nix
jetzt exzellent
der ist ja schon da der captain penge ist am start ein knäherbär habe ich vorhin auch schon
gesehen also habe ich den chat geflasht das weiß ich nicht wer alles schon da ist 42 leute sind da
big brain sub box camping der akte ist da der gelber 905 im imil 08 du kann das kann ich
aussprechen aber es auch da da ich noch ist auch am start der name na sana 3 ist auch da der moon
bier desmunder auch am stadtärztekommen sie alle hier so und
habe ich irgendwas verpasst gestern ich wollte ja gestern eigentlich und kommen noch aber irgendwie
habe ich dann ich muss gerade mal gucken ich habe nämlich mein tablet liegen und immer wenn
ich irgendwas auf youtube finde was ich mir denke das könnte man sich zusammen hier angucken dann
speichere ich das immer auf tablet als als bookmark guck mal ob da irgendwas dabei ist was ich darauf mache 2
stunden nee ich glaube das ist jetzt nicht dass das das richtige ansonsten ist da irgendwie nichts
dabei wir können uns das video von elektro boom zu 5g angucken das ist nämlich wahrscheinlich
ziemlich gut der macht immer gute videos als glaube ich habe noch kein richtig schlechtes
video gesehen bisher und ich bin mal gespannt wie oft dass ich selbst schock dieses video wieder
aber zum einstieg wir gucken eine runde battlefield das müssen später auch gucken der step-by-step
guide hacker werden das muss man später auch noch angucken wie wir richtig krasse hexer werden
ich kenne den channel nicht aber so wie ich mir das angeguckt habe scheint das ernst der
inhalt zu sein und und kein wie hieß das andere youtube collective ja ja ja genau wie spricht
man ja und y collective why collective keine ahnung also anscheinend ist das weil ist das
was ernstes ja terminal auf grünen stellen das schon mal nicht schlecht ob er bei terminal auf
grünen stellen sind ich habe letztens echt mal wieder matrix geguckt und ich muss sagen für das
das ist ein film der club 99 rausgekommen ist oder so die special effects sind echt nicht schlecht
also ja klar du kannst das heute schon geiler machen aber dafür dass es echt immer noch ein
super stimmiger film werden wo in den google kickstart das ist das ist wenn wenn es uns
heute richtig wenn es uns heute richtig danach ist die die die krassen hexer im wimm zu sehen
der ist auch immer noch im wimm am start okay wir können wir kommen erst mal am anfang wir
gucken wir gucken eine runde bettel field runde bettel field kann man sich am anfang immer angucken
dann wird man ein bisschen wach und dann kann man sich auf den warum leute warum hört meine
meine video leiste an der minimap von bettel field auf exposed illuminati alle sie sehen
das die die leiste die buffer leiste hört auf an der minimap warum weiß die buffer leiste von
youtube was in game von content gezeigt wird
ja gut man sieht sie bloß nicht sie ist ja noch da
ein fall für galileo müsste galileo aus galileo da brauchst irgendwie die missbusters oder was
gibt es das überhaupt noch die folgen wurden auch immer schlechter 10 kram überhaupt noch
ich glaube gibt es nicht mehr die folgen waren so schlecht irgendwann na gut irgendwann sind
auch alle alle alle müsst gebastelt es wird doch großartig machen wie ist diese sehr wie
ist diese eine sendung ich weiß nicht wie ich da drauf kommen leute ich weiß es jetzt
ein bisschen eklig so zum aufstehen ich habe irgendwie noch im im hinterkopf so eine sendung
was war das dann das war nicht joko und klas auf mtv oder wo die früher war nee das war
in den englischen was war das noch mal ich kann mich gerade erinnern das war in der sendung da
haben sie jemand in den klo häuschen gesetzt es soll davon auch das kann tatsächlich sein da
haben sie irgendein in ein klo häuschen gesetzt und haben das klo häuschen dann an so eine schleuder
gemacht und sprich war das das kann checkers gewissen sein ja so eine scheiße am wahrsten
und das war das alter so eine scheiße da haben sie einen klo häuschen gesetzt haben das klo
häuschen an so eine also ein voll voll gekacktes klo häuschen an so eine schleuder gemacht und
haben die dann in die luft geschleudert richtig eklig ich finde ich finde es ja auch toll ich
finde es toll dass das irgendwie die meisten leute kennen ich weiß nicht wie ich da drauf
komme jetzt total total random eigentlich warum kommt man von von wir gucken uns jetzt ein
battlefield video an warum hat man auf einmal ein bild im kopf wo einer im klo häuschen
sitzt und in die luft geschleudert wird das ergibt überhaupt keinen sinn small brain vielleicht
nostalgie vom battlefield ja ich weiß es kann sein vorher hat mir youtube ein video empfehlt
irgendwie dass das leben mit 130 plus iku und da habe ich ja mal so durch das video
durchgeklickt das ist das ist langweilig muss man es jetzt nicht angucken durchgeklickt
am ende kam dann raus leute mit 130 plus iku sind auch normale leute habe ich mir gedacht
was das hätte ich jetzt nie gedacht dafür brauchst du 30 minuten video exzellent da
bin ich froh dass ich nur 129 habe da falle ich noch nicht drunter glaubst du deno löst
note ab nee glaube ich nicht und ich glaube aus folgendem folgendem grund nicht weil
deno keine packages verwenden kann oder kann deno mittlerweile npm packages verwenden oder
oder note packages verwenden wahrscheinlich nicht standard library ist auch komplett anders
da müsste dann irgendwie einen node compatibility layer einbauen oder so ich glaube nicht dass
deno note absetzen ablösen wird weil der riesen vorteil ich meine das ding hat gerade
aufwind ohne ende ja das ist ein plugin das ding hat gerade riesen aufwind also wer sich
fragt was es ist das ist eine neue ja das ist quasi v8 also dass die gleiche javascript
engine die auch in chrome drin ist ein node drinne ist die haben v8 genommen haben es
aber ein bisschen schöner gerappt als node mit typescript support es ist kein komisches
komische zäge schwuppel mehr es ist rust layer es ist eigentlich eine richtig coole
sache viele sachen testing tools ist auch alles eingebaut das problem was ich halt sehe
ist auch wenn es gerade riesen aufwind um an 60.000 sternen ist übelst krass ich weiß
gar nicht was node.js auf github für sterne hat wahrscheinlich mehr guck mal fast 70.000
da sie sind da auf dem weg aber warum ich nicht glaube dass deno node.js ablösen wird
auf nächster zeit ist das wichtigste am ganzen node.js ökosystem ist doch dass es so viele
pakete gibt es ist nicht umsonst so dass wenn du irgendeinen javascript anwendung clones
gibt und machst dann einen npm install dass der erstmal das halbe internet nachinstalliert
also ich glaube ohne npm pakete wird das nix da sie müssen ja alles neu programmieren
das oder portieren das werden die wenigsten machen oder wenn wenn doch dann dann ist es
auf jeden fall die bessere alternative so wir gucken uns wir gucken uns jetzt eine runde
battlefield an bin als exzellent ach leute ich muss ja noch meine vm anmachen für dass
die fragen mit gelockt werden ich sehe übrigens gerade die text von meinem von meinem stream
hier auf der linken seite da steht dann steht drinne ingenieurswesen ich bin mir nicht
bewusst dass ich das da reingeschrieben habe aber vielleicht habe ich da nicht dran gedacht
als ich den tag auf englisch stopp engineering steht da einfach drinne was ja passt ja lehrreich
lehrreich ingenieurswesen softwareentwicklung programmierung deutsch irl exzellent und ask
me anything ama lehrreich ey leute ihr könnt nicht sagen dass da stream nicht lehrreich
ist guckt mal hier guckt mal passt mal auf wo bloß ah moment das ist immer das ist jetzt
so wir das neue klips moment klips das ist übrigens ultra laggy das ist ultra laggy
das neu twitch designer wie komm ich jetzt auf videos wo
ihr wisst ihr was ich beim neuen twitch design ich verstehe ist es sieht im prinzip mehr
oder weniger aus wie das alte bedient sich aber anders warum die man weiß doch wie sehr
die leute an was hängen ja guckt mal lehrreich das ist der beweis dafür dass man stream lehrreich
ist also man sieht ja hier wenn man wenn aus 10 iso runterladen will geht das nicht man
kann dieses tool runterladen um dann c2 ho hat geklippt das muss lehrreich sein selbst
in iso zu erzeugen ich zeige ich zeige euch jetzt mal was was man machen kann ihr geht
einfach hier drauf und sagt developer mode und dann stellt ihr um auf irgendwie in den
mobile gerät sagen wir jetzt irgendwie kann ein iphone 6 oder sowas dann aktualisiert ihr
die seite und iso download excellent fertig das war es ist die leute lehrreich das heißt
der tag ist ok lehrreich das heißt der tag ist ok was zum teufel monkaS was war das
zwitschle auch das bisher ein bisschen brauchen würde ich sagen steuerung w steuerung w nicht
steuerung c steuerung w big brain zwitschle oder ok wir können uns mal battlefield plays an
der kevlar benn ist am start bester name
jetzt werden sie gesprayt ich sehe es schon ich sehe schon m16 weggesprayt und die gegner
checken wieder nix vorwetten lechak 1 9 7 8 dankeschön für den subscription big brain
ich glaube alle nuptube untereinander im 16 11 monate poggers
lehrer in for a real treat we've got i think around 15 minutes of absolutely incredible
battlefield rambo moment from lucky why is it so rot hinten
typical battlefield 3 this is clear geschichte doch kein mensch verwendet
moment ist es jetzt battlefield 3 oder battlefield 4 das battlefield 4 oder was ist battlefield
3 ich erkenne den unterschied nicht mehr ob das ist 4 na der chat sagt 4 der chat der
chat muss es wissen der chat beißt sowas immer warum ist die map so groß weil er sie
großgestellt hat was ist der münchen in dem fahrstuhl los alter was ist mit den gegnern
los sind die alle afk die müssen afk sein anders geht das
den afk fahrstuhl das geile war an diesen battlefields gerade an battlefield 3 war dass
du noch richtig gut durch die gegner durchdrehen konntest den fahrstuhl gab es in battlefield
3 nicht ja sie haben versucht mit ein bisschen weniger clusterfuck zu machen hat aber nicht
funktioniert rick lips in todays episode is from oh der crossbow or alex k playing on
same crossing he is going to single handedly sort out this game for his team it's rush
and that objective needs to be sorted out he gets the minute moment moment das battlefield
3 na ich kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern dass es in battlefield 3 einen crossbow gegeben
hat
ja ich habe ja alle battlefield 3 addons gespielt aber ich kann mich an den crossbow jetzt
nicht erinnern wahrscheinlich habe schlichter greifen die crossbow gespielt weil er gesackt
hat
richtige pp gas wieder als gegner am start
das ist das wisst ihr das geile wie das das battlefield 3 hatte so ein geiles gefühl
wenn du gut flank gemacht hast und du bist da hochgelaufen also wenn du hier reingelaufen
bist die gegner checken schon wenn du wenn du wenn du das gesehen hast hast dir gedacht
alter in your face jetzt geht's ab das wusstest du schon dass es jetzt gleich klatscht in
battlefield 3
gut gegner natürlich wieder komplett brain dead aber das muss so sein sonst kriegst du
sowas nicht gebacken die sehen ihn auch alle nicht die sehen ihn auch alle nicht
monkaS ja 800 mal 600 das beste
wie das null verzieht ja gut da zieht einfach nach unten da zieht einfach nach unten der
recoil war ja übelst einfach zu handeln bei den meisten war von battlefield 3 einfach
nach unten ziehen
da oben liegt er drin
das wort das wort magier dass das sagt immer so oft in seinen videos back range aber ist
back range das es klingt irgendwie nicht richtig
boah da stehen so und kapieren wieder nix
das ging auch noch in battlefield weil du das gegner durchschießen konntest in battlefield
boah da ist ja schon wieder ein typ schau wieder schau wieder der gleiche typ gleiche stelle
man konnte durch den smoke spotten ne ja die sounds waren das beste battlefield 3 sounds
huge schau wieder
die haben auch keinen spark sag mal
also ganz ehrlich leute ganz ganz ehrlich was ist das für ein absolut ppega gegner
gewesen gerade
wie schön sie weggesprayt werden
so ist das nice
ne nicht hardline sah erstmal so aus von der farbe her ganz komische was ist das für
komische farbfilter
hatte irgendwie den retro farbfilter oder
ja das stimmt schon man bekommt immer bock wenn man die video sieht auf battlefield 3
und battlefield 3 ist nicht mal gut spielbar
gibt es gibt recht also es gibt nicht viel battlefield 4 ist deutlich besser spielbar
noch
wie viele shotgun clips heute
die wurden bestimmt geflamed leute mit shotguns werden in battlefield immer geflamed
locker natürlich was hatten wir heute metro metro metro locker
schau wieder back raged der back raged aber ganz schön viel heute
wie sie weggesprayt werden
und wie sich wieder mal kaum ein gegner umdreht
und wie die battlefield hits nicht registrieren
wie die hits nicht registrieren im battlefield
und sogar mit ok den clip darf ich zeigen er hat wiederbelebt
das ist ok sonst kriege ich gleich wieder geflamed
max warum zeigst du so viele leute die killen und nicht wiederbelebt
ok es hat aber auch keiner bock irgendwie was gegen den panzer zu machen
oder
es ist es ist auf jeden fall schon mal nicht das er es vor
aber ich glaube nicht dass der heute irgendwie bock hat noch bei level 3 zu spielen
ne der survive weil die gegner pepega style sind
aber das brauchst du ansonsten kriegst du ja so feets nicht hin wenn die gegner mit
hier spielen
diesen bug dass teilweise granaten angezeigt werden wo kein sind gibt es ja seit release
vom battlefield 3
spray spray spray spray spray spray spray spray spray
das einzige warum ich die ik nicht so gerne gespielt habe es weil die so lange nachgeladen
hat das war halt das geile an der m4 16 oder
auch an der m16 da hat er einfach mal magazine wechselt
dafür 3 ist eindeutig besser dafür 1 1 keck keck trübbel juh und battlefield 5 ist keck
quadruple juh
dafür 3 wurde zwingend auch wiederbelebt weil das halt total op war aber das war gut
also ich fand ich fand das nicht schlecht
der mutter cup
was hat er da für eine waffe mit wahrscheinlich triggermark oder so
den habe ich auch noch nicht mal den kopf gesehen vom gegner gerade
schön weggesprayt so ein battlefield wird es in naher zukunft nicht geben sagt der timbo
ich hoffe ja dass sie es irgendwie gebacken kriegen also ich spekuliere ja nicht drauf
dass es ein battlefield in noise bed company 2 neues battlefield 3 geben werde also von
dem kaliber aber mir wird es ja schon reichen wenn es ein battlefield geben würde was ich
nicht scheiße finde
was ich wenigstens gerne spiele
und das sind aber schöne shots das sind das sind paar schöne shots
die liegen auch wieder die liegen schon wieder rum bewegen sich aber das ist nice
ist mir aufgefallen das battlefield 3 eines der ersten games war mit diesem sniper scope
mittlerweile haben das total viele games in warzone ist es ja auch so dass wenn einer
home sniper dass du das visier siehst
schon wieder shotgun clip
die gegner gut was sollen sie machen sie laufen durch ok jetzt wird nichts gecheckt
es wird nichts gecheckt
erstmal schon slug ammo am start wahrscheinlich zumindest über welche range er teilweise
killt
aber kann es sein dass es nur metro metro locker metro war und sein kostet sein kostet
oder so
komm wie die reinrenner
Ah locker, was sonst, Tim Perlmarket haben wir auch eins und und Savote haben wir auch
eins oder?
Aber das meiste ist locker und Metro, war das japanische Zeichen auch okay, kann auch
sein.
Die Gegner checken es halt wieder nicht, aber es ist auch schwierig da einen raus zu
kriegen, wenn man da nicht gerade irgendeinen RPG hat oder so.
Moving on to a console clip from Orion, Operation Locker, M16A4 and a load of enemies taken
out in a big point stack as well as he tries to get into the tower on C and control it.
Ist das ein M16 ja, oh, ach stimmt ich vergaß, man konnte sich ja lehnen in dem Spiel,
das sieht man kaum, stimmt man konnte sich ja lehnen, sieht fast aus wie Warzone jetzt
hier gerade.
Hatte den gerade, die, okay, Travel zwei Monate, Dankeschön, Excellent, Subscription, ja das
stimmt, das ist wirklich ein tryhard Setup, aber warum auch nicht, ich habe am liebsten
ACR gespielt in Battlefield 4.
Oh Gott, hier die Silenced, Silenced G18 am Start, das sind doch Bots, ja, die sind
halt richtige PP-Gegner, aber das musst du, sonst kriegst du nicht so lange Feats hin,
das ist wie bei den ganzen Free for All Gameplays früher, wo ich dann teilweise 30-0 oder sonst
was gespielt habe, das geht auch nur weil die Gegner total hängen geblieben sind.
Wie das, das komplette Gegenteil ist halt Modern Warfare mit Skill-Based Matchmaking, da hat
keiner Spaß.
Also stimmt, wir sind ja nicht signed in.
Okay, was gucken wir dann als nächstes, was gucken wir dann als nächstes, wir haben
zur Auswahl, ich zeige euch mal die Videos, die wir heute zur Auswahl haben, wir haben,
frag mich nicht, wie ich wieder auf das Video gekommen bin, vielleicht hatten wir das auch
schon, keine Ahnung, vielleicht hatten wir das schon, das ist wieder sowas, wo ich mich
ein bisschen drüber lustig machen kann, je nach Empfehlung, die 10 Minuten History Javas
Skript, ich glaube, der macht das immer ganz lustig, irgendeine uralt Doku 10 Minuten lang
von 1972, wie die Welt im Jahr 2000 aussieht, da habe ich den Anfang schon geguckt, das
ist teilweise echt, echt, naja, nicht so ganz zutreffend, dann haben wir das Video Hacker
werden, der Step-by-Step Guide, Musenik 10 Monate, exellent, ups, falscher Knopf, äh,
ne, das brauchen wir nicht, äh, dann hier nochmal der Kugelmagnet Eddy, der sich über
Battlefield 5 aufregt, haben wir ein bisschen Black Ops 1, dann haben wir ja irgendwo, äh,
warum habe ich denn das eigentlich auf, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht taugt es, frag einen
Millionär, 5G, äh, der macht echt gute Videos, und den krassen Hexer, den gucken wir uns
zum Schluss an, das Video lohnt sich nicht, welches Video, das Linus Video, komm wir gucken
jetzt 5G, okay, Hi, ich wusste es, die Videos fangen immer gleich an, so geil, bisschen
lauter machen, Hi, achso, Ops laufe, das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht,
das stimmt nicht, 5G, also ja, ich weiß, dass er das wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich sagt,
das ist auch was, was ich am Anfang gedacht habe, dass 5G 5 Gigahertz ist, das stimmt
aber gar nicht, 5G ist, äh, fragt mich nicht, 300 Gigahertz oder sowas, das ist einfach
nur 5th Generation, also, äh, bisschen, bisschen doof, bisschen doof benannt, ja.
Okay, ja, da war ich ja gar nicht so falsch, ist laut genug oder zu laut, ist laut genug,
zu laut oder zu leise, glaube ich, bei mir ist es ein bisschen zu laut, aber ich weiß
nicht, wie es bei euch ist, passt so, okay, ja, Aluhut ist raus, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
Aluhut ist raus, MonkaS, fuck, stimmt, eigentlich sollte es nicht 5G heißen, sondern 5C, 5,
5, keine Ahnung, 5 mal Corona, beste Antwort, no, oh nice, Alter, mein Headset, wartet mal,
ich muss mal kurz mein Headset abstocken, das geht auf der einen Seite nicht mehr, was
ist da los, jetzt, jetzt geht es wieder, okay, okay, okay, okay, wir überspringen mal kurz
die Werbung, ja, totaler, Alter, mein Headset, ja, alle recht, dass, diese ganze Geschichte
mit Handys und Krebsverursachen und WLAN und so, es gibt ja auch Leute, was ist denn
mit meinem scheiß Headset, wer sagt, das liegt gar nicht am Headset, das liegt da an diesem
komischen Verlängerungsteil, das wollte ich jetzt sagen, also, ja, also es gibt ja immer
noch Leute, die sich hinstellen und sagen, ich schalte abends meinen Router aus, weil
die WLAN die Luft verschmutzt und sowas, was willst du machen, ja, wow, fuck, jetzt, jetzt
geht es, exzellent, exzellent, oh, penetrate, penetrated, okay, Leute, ich muss mal kurz
mein Headset fixen, wartet mal, ich höre mich selbst nicht richtig, ich mache mich mal
kurz aus, wo sind wir hier offen,
so, jetzt sollte es wieder funktionieren, okay, also, wo ist er denn jetzt gerade stehengeblieben,
muss er kurz zurück, genau, er zeigt jetzt gerade, dass man Licht durch Gewebe scheinen
lassen kann, ja, das habe ich auch schon gesehen, ist jetzt eigentlich Neues, macht man die Hand
vor die Sonne, wobei, ne, die Sonne ist so hell, das bringt nichts, aber trotzdem, oder vor
eine Lampe, ja, das ist auch so eine Sache, wo ich mich immer frage, was ist mit den Leuten
los, ne, sichtbares Licht hat eine viel höhere Frequenz als, oder Wellenlänge als 5G, ich
weiß nicht, wie die drauf kommen, dass man sich den ganzen Tag Licht ausgesetzt sieht
und 5G dann aber der Teufel ist, ey, kleinere Wellenlänge, ja, höhere Frequenz, kleinere
Wellenlänge, hast recht, und der Witz ist, der Witz ist, dass
in der Nähe, oder je nachdem, wenn man sich das mal so die, so die Charakteristik von
so einem Sendemast anguckt, dass wenn du direkt neben dem Sendemast stehst, bekommst du weniger
ab, als wenn du weiter wegstehst von, aber 5G verbreitet ja auch Corona, ne, ich weiß
nicht, warum sich diese Sachen bei gewissen Leuten quasi, quasi immer, immer gruppiert,
ja, du hast, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung, man sollte diese ganze Verschwörungstheorie-Geschichte
ein bisschen bedachter verwenden, man kann nicht zu allem sagen, was einem nicht gefällt,
das ist Verschwörungstheorie, das ist ja das, was wir aktuell auch Mainstreammedien mäßig
passiert, wenn irgendwas ist, was nicht so in das Mainstream-Bild reinpasst, wird heute
ganz schnell gesagt, Verschwörungstheorie hier, Verschwörungstheorie da, für mich ist Verschwörungstheorie
sowas wie in der Richtung, wir sind nicht auf dem Mond gelandet oder Obamas Bodyguard
ist ein Echsenmensch oder die Erde ist flach oder sowas, das ist für mich eine Verschwörungstheorie,
wenn jetzt einer sagt, er ist dagegen, dass alle Leute zwangsgeimpft werden, dann ist
das für mich keine Verschwörungstheorie, sondern ich find's eigentlich meistens mal
ganz interessant, sich anzuhören, was die Leute dann da so zu sagen haben, man kann
nicht alles mundtot machen in Form von Verschwörungstheorie, das find ich eh ein bisschen blöd, aber gerade
bei dieser 5G-Geschichte ist halt auch so ein Ding, das sammelt sich bei Leuten, also es
ist witzig, wie gehäuft die Sachen auftreten, also du hast beispielsweise 5G und Corona-Impfgegner
und Flacherdeleute, das ist so, irgendwie sammeln sich das gerne bei bestimmten Personen,
ich weiß auch nicht, woran das liegt, es ist ja nicht so, als hätten da nicht manche durchaus
sinnvolle Argumente für manches ihre Ansichten, und es ist ja auch nicht so, als ist prinzipiell
nur, weil das von einer speziellen Person kommt, das pauschal falsch oder so, aber manche
Sachen gruppieren sich einfach gerne bei bestimmten Leuten, ich weiß auch nicht, was
da los ist.
Zumindest, was ich jetzt eigentlich sagen wollte, bei dieser ganzen 5G-Geschichte, wenn man sich
überlegt, wie viel Zeug man jetzt schon ausgesetzt ist, und das normales Licht, was ist denn das,
ein Elektron, ein Photon, was auch immer, mehr Energie hat, als jegliches 4G oder 5G,
was soll da großartig passieren, zumal die Sendeleistung von so einem Mast jetzt auch
nicht so extrem hoch ist, dass es dich grillt oder so, naja, was auch immer, wir gucken
uns das Video jetzt erstmal weiter an, und man muss ja auch unterscheiden, dass das quasi
Strahlung ist, die deine Zellen kaputt machen kann, beziehungsweise Strahlung ist, wie sagen
wir mal, in einer Mikrowelle, es gibt ja Leute, die haben Angst, dass die Mikrowelle radioaktiv
ist oder so was, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, meine Mutter früher hat gesagt, ich soll
mich nicht vor die Mikrowelle stellen, und hat das quasi begründet, das wäre so was
wie ein Atomkraftwerk im Endeffekt, richtig Hardcore-Pepega, die hat das irgendwie mit
so einer Art Atomkraftwerk verglichen, so nach dem Motto, das ist ja auch gefährlich,
ich hab das ja damals geglaubt, oh je, da muss man aufpassen, und ich hab lange Zeit
deswegen gedacht, als ich klein war, Mikrowelle wäre irgendwie radioaktiv oder hätte irgendwie
Gamma-Strahlung oder was auch immer, gut, damals wusste ich nicht, dass es Gamma-Strahlung
heißt, aber total hängen geblieben, das einzige, was dir passieren kann in einer Mikrowelle
ist, oder wenn du deine Hand in die Mikrowelle legst, ist, die wird kochen, das Wasser wird
anfangen zu kochen in deiner Hand, das ist nicht angenehm, das ist mit Sicherheit nicht
angenehm, und das macht deine Hand auch kaputt, aber anders, als das beispielsweise ein Atomkraftwerk
machen würde, das verändert deine Zellen, das kocht halt deine Hand, das heißt da ist
ganz entscheidend, mit wie viel Leistung du den ganzen Kram abkriegst, und das ist halt
sowas von gering, von so einem Sendemast, ja vielleicht wird es ein bisschen warm,
aber die einzelnen, ich kann es ja immer nicht merken, das sind Elektronen, es müssen
eigentlich Photonen sein, weil Elektronen, naja, was auch immer, die haben einfach bei
der Frequenz nicht genug Energie, dass die deine Zellen kaputt machen können, und das
einzige, was logischerweise passieren kann, ist, wie bei einer Mikrowelle, dass es warm
wird, allerdings halt nicht so warm wie bei einer Mikrowelle, weil die Leistung nicht
so groß ist, so, Physiker-FPS, ja, ja wir gucken uns mal das Video an, ich denke mal,
das kommt jetzt gleich noch, oh jetzt, jetzt wird es, jetzt wird es, ich muss den Anfang
mitkriegen, jetzt wird es advanced hier, und übrigens wisst ihr warum Mikrowellen überhaupt
das Essen warm machen, das ist, weil die Mikrowelle die Wassermoleküle durch Reibung zum schwingen
bringt, oder zum aufheizt, deswegen, die Mikrowelle schaltet ganz schnell hin und her, und dadurch
entsteht Reibung in den Wassermolekülen und die werden warm, so, also das hat nichts mit
irgendwie Radioaktivität oder sonst was zu tun, oder auch nix mit Magic, wenn das Ding
trocken ist, dann wird es nicht warm, richtig, also sag mal so, wenn du da ein Stück Holz
reinlegst, ein Stück Holz ist auch, wenn du da ein Papiertaschentuch reinlegst, dann
passiert nix, oh jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt like a phoenix, excellent, excellent, Mikrowellen
regen Schwingungsniveaus an und diese relaxieren unter Wärmeabgabe wieder in den Grundzustand,
excellent, so ist es, so sieht es aus, ist das so, körtgesagt, ist das so, körtgesagt,
ist das so?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
But let me simplify it here, every cell makes a copy of itself by splitting the DNA to half
and then rebuilding the other half one letter at a time to get two full DNAs to pass the
genetic information, if the DNA gets corrupted right at the one percent essential letters
that matter, well that's bad, the corrupted cell will malfunction, body has many ways
to get rid of the corrupted cell though, the cell has a self destruct system just for this,
it can be detected and destroyed by the immunity system, so a bunch of essential DNA code must
get corrupted for the cell to become cancerous, it must disable self destruct, disable detection
by the immunity system, lure the body to direct all the resources to it and enable fast multiplication,
so you can imagine the chance of one cell getting cancerous is very low, one in a gazillion,
we have a lot of cells, really, is that so high, fifty percent, seriously, that means
the chance of getting cancerous is almost as high as the chance, it's just as high as
the chance of not getting cancerous, is that really that high, but that's pretty monkaS,
that I can't even imagine, is that really that high, yes, come on guys, if it's in the USA,
it won't be much different for us, yes, only in the USA, why should it be significantly
different in the USA than here, chat, the USA is different, they eat more barbecue pitboys,
but that's really high, that's really high,
yes, exactly, okay, they are photons too, I can't always remember that,
hhh, that's right, how often he himself is shocked in his videos,
he is shocked, with that he knows how to do it,
okay,
Das kann Nervostimulation aus 0 Hz DC machen. DC ist 0 Hz. Ich habe es in einem alten Video getestet.
Der ist so hart drauf teilweise, Alter.
Die Holz, ich kenne die ganzen Videos von dem. Ich muss mir nicht die Kompilation angucken. Ich habe das so alle schon geguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ich würde da nicht unbedingt dran riechen.
Aber der Schmerz, wenn die Elektrizität zu hoch ist, ist so hoch, dass du dich beinahe schnell verlassen oder aus anderen Komplikationen sterben kannst.
Der echte Proxy kommt aus dem Iran.
Das ist der andere Gegner, der Heizung. Elektrizität kreiert Heizung durch Konduktorresistenz.
Depending auf die Anzahl der Elektrizität, kann es von unbekannten Heizungen, zu Tissuewellen oder direkt auf deinem Körper ausblühen.
Der höhere Frequenz-Exposure kommt aus Radiowagen.
Radiowagen, die Elektromagnetik-Wagen oder Licht sind, können Voltage über den Konduktor generieren. Aber die Voltage über den Konduktor, depends auf der Weileinheit oder der Frequenz.
Aber wenn die Frequenz hoch ist und die Weileinheit kompatibel zu deinem Körper oder dem Konduktor in der Elektronik ist, kann es eine Potenzialdifferenz über den Konduktor kreieren.
Also kann es Strom durch deinen Körper geben, aber die Energie der Source muss sehr hoch sein, um genug Strom durch deinen Körper zu kreieren, wie in einem Mikrowaveofen.
Wenn der Konduktor zu deinem Körper hoch ist, kann es Strom durch deinen Körper geben, aber die Energie der Source muss sehr hoch sein, wie in einem Mikrowaveofen.
Wenn der Konduktor zu deinem Körper hoch ist, kann es Strom durch deinen Körper gehen, wie in einem Mikrowaveofen.
Ah, ja.
Perfekt.
Ja, der erklärt das wirklich gut.
Ja, aber Corona kommt aus Wuhan und Wuhan hat 5G-Ausbau.
Ja.
Perfekt.
Ja gut, was abgefackelt ist, kann ja auch schlecht Krebs entwickeln, das ist ja dann kaputt.
Das ist ein echt gutes Video.
Der macht echt gute Videos, also kann ich nur empfehlen.
So.
Noch ein Video zur Mikrowelle. Wir haben jetzt genug Five Head Content geguckt erstmal.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten? Hacker werden.
Hacker, komm, der Step-by-Step-Guide zum Hacksor, den gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Muss ich gucken, wie mein krasser Hackermann wird.
Ich werde mein krasser Hackermann.
Wundervollen guten Tag und herzlich willkommen zu dem wohl am meisten gewünschten Video auf meinem ganzen Kanal.
Und zwar, wie werde ich Hacker? Und zwar ein am besten Step-by-Step-Guide.
Einfach schnell tippen.
Da denken alle, du bist Hacker.
Den Step-Guide, den ihr, wie ihr gleich sehen werdet, mit Vorsicht genießen müsst.
Das sind nämlich eigentlich nur zwei Schritte, aber ja, wir werden sehen, worauf wir hinaus wollen.
Bitte guckt das Video komplett an.
Das heißt, hier werden viele Fragen beantwortet, die ich immer wieder bekomme.
Und ja, das Video hier kann euch wirklich helfen.
Also das Wichtigste ist erstmal, ich wollte es gerade sagen, der Chat hat es auch gerade gesagt,
das Wichtigste ist erstmal, dass man so ein Hoodie hat.
So ein Kapuzen-Pulli.
Das ist das Wichtigste. Danach der Rest ist einfach.
Videos helfen, aber dieses Video hier ganz besonders natürlich.
So, zunächst einmal müssen wir klären, was können Hacker denn eigentlich alles?
Und hier habe ich mal bloß die zwei Teams aufgeschrieben.
Das Red Team und das Blue Team.
Das Red Team ist das klassische Hacker-Team, die greisen an sozusagen.
Die können Sachen wie Penetration-Testing, Schwachstellen finden,
Exploits entwickeln, Malware entwickeln, Social Engineering und noch vieles mehr,
was ich niemals aufgeschrieben habe.
Das Blue Team ist in der Verteidigung.
Das heißt, die wollen einfach nur ihre Anwendung schützen im Normalfall.
Und ja, die können Sachen wie Forensik, was ich niemals aufgeschrieben habe,
Kryptographie, Security.
Also ich bin eher Team Kappa Pride.
Und noch vieles, vieles mehr, was hier nicht mal drauf steht.
Und mir ist klar, dass das für die meisten von euch einfach viel zu viel ist,
beziehungsweise eigentlich für alle von euch.
Denn die Wahrheit ist, eigentlich kann niemand wirklich alles.
Niemand, aber auch wirklich gar niemand kann alles in der IT.
Wer euch das sagt, der liebt einfach nur.
Das stimmt. Ja, richtig.
Ich lerne jeden Tag neues Zeug, teilweise von Dingen,
die ich dachte, dass ich sie schon seit Jahren kann,
lerne ich gerade wieder neu oder lerne einfach neue Dinge kennen,
weil einfach mehr in der Technologie entwickelt wird,
als man überhaupt haben kann oder als man überhaupt lesen kann.
Ja, das stimmt.
Es kommen so viele Paper raus, auch zur IT generell,
dass man einfach nicht mehr hinterherkommt.
Und ja, wenn ihr mit ein bisschen was anfängt, dann ist das auch völlig fine.
Einfach nur sagen wir mal, einige Bücher zur Programmierung
und dann kommt vielleicht noch Netzwerktechnik drauf
und dann kommt das nächste und so weiter und so fort.
Und das kann etwas überwältigend sein.
Natürlich geht das nur gescheit, wenn man sich auch dafür interessiert.
Also, sonst fehlt aber einfach so der innere Antrieb dafür.
Verliert relativ schnell den Überblick, was das eigentlich alles soll.
Und deswegen hier so ein kleines bisschen eine Guideline,
wie man vielleicht in die richtige Richtung kommt.
Und ja, natürlich, dieses Video hier ist nicht gesponsert,
aber der Spruch Just do it passt hier einfach perfekt dazu.
Denn eigentlich wollen wir in diesem Video klären,
was genau gehört denn eigentlich zu diesem IT?
Was gehört denn eigentlich zum Hacken?
Und was gehört denn eigentlich zur IT überhaupt?
Tastatur.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so logisch, wie man sich das vielleicht vorstellen möchte.
Die IT ist mittlerweile, würde ich behaupten, ein teilweise größeres Feld
als die Humanmedizin oder generell die Medizin.
Da kann man schon mal relativ leicht lost werden.
Und wenn man einfach nur anfängt, dann ist das meistens...
Deswegen finde ich es auch immer lustig, wenn Leute der Meinung sind,
der IT-Support weiß einfach alles.
So nach dem Motto, ja, also der dritte Pixel von links,
der ist halt heute Morgen nur noch gelb, was ist das?
Ja, woher soll ich das wissen?
Wenn dann der Support sagt, ja keine Ahnung, muss ich mir erst mal angucken.
Warum sind sie denn IT-Support, weil sie da keine Ahnung davon haben?
Also, da hat er schon recht, dass die IT in dem Sinn gibt es nicht.
Das mag ein riesengroßes Sammelsurium sein, so Überbegriff,
aber es gibt so viel.
Das ist ja auch das, was ich immer sage, wenn es ums Thema Ausbildung geht.
Egal, ob Fachinformatik, ob Systemintegration, Anwendungsentwicklung
oder eine von diesen vier neuen Fachinformatiker-Richtungen.
Im Prinzip hängt es ganz davon entscheidend ab,
wo man landet, was man halt auch macht.
Und natürlich auch, was einen persönlich interessiert.
Deswegen sage ich immer, man sollte das machen,
was einen persönlich interessiert.
Weil darin wird man wahrscheinlich auch gut werden,
weil man den Antrieb hat, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Und dann, umso besser man in einem Gebiet wird,
umso größer sind die Chancen, dass man in dem Gebiet arbeitet,
umso mehr kann man damit machen, umso besser wird man wieder.
So, weiter.
Das ist schon ein großer Hilfeschritt.
Das heißt, wenn man sich einfach mit einem PC hinsetzt und irgendwas tut.
Aber wirklich alles, was ihr tut, ist hilfreich.
Es ist hilfreich, wenn ihr mit Linux einfach nur Linux benutzt.
Es ist auch hilfreich, wenn ihr mal hinterfragt,
hey Mensch, wie funktioniert denn das da eigentlich, was ich gerade mache?
Was ist das eigentlich gerade für ein Programm?
Und wie ist das eigentlich überhaupt aufgebaut?
All diese Dinge sind komplett hilfreich
und können sehr, sehr viel euch bringen.
Ja, aber was natürlich bei vielen auch so ein bisschen brennt,
und die Frage will ich auch ganz kurz hier noch anschneiden,
bevor wir wirklich in den Step-by-Step-Guide einschalten.
Ich weiß, dass so viel davor kommt, aber das muss leider sein.
Und zwar hacken ist eigentlich gar nicht illegal.
Nö, warum auch?
Hacken ist absolut legal, zumindest wenn ihr die Erlaubnis habt.
Man darf auch nicht vergessen,
man darf mit seiner eigenen Hardware machen, was man will.
In Deutschland zum Glück noch.
Erlaubnis zu bekommen, ist gar nicht mehr so schwer, wie wir hier sehen können.
Sogar Google erlaubt euch, dass ihr die Plattform angreift.
Das bezieht sich nicht nur auf Google, sondern auf YouTube.
Ja, mal ganz davon abgesehen.
Mit Sachen, die man daheim hat, sei es irgendwelche Tablets
oder irgendwelche anderen Geschichten,
du darfst damit machen, was du willst.
Das kann dir keiner verbieten.
Und auf Blogger und eigentlich auf noch sehr, sehr viele andere Plattformen,
wobei das natürlich nicht von Google ist, sondern von anderen.
Ihr müsst euch nur genau an diese Vereinbarungen halten,
und die waren jetzt nicht vollständig.
Das heißt, ihr habt jetzt nicht einfach die Kompletterlaubnis,
alles mit YouTube und Google zu machen, was ihr wollt.
Aber ihr könnt definitiv mehrere Plattformen,
zum Beispiel auch Twitter oder Instagram, so weit ich weiß, haben das auch.
Dürft ihr angreifen.
Die haben auch Baumtip-Programme.
Aber ihr müsst euch immer an die Vereinbarungen halten.
Und tatsächlich wird es auch wirklich gut bezahlt.
Zum Beispiel kriegt man hier von Google,
wenn man wirklich eine Reward-Code-Execution finden sollte,
über 30.000 Dollar.
Ja, mach das mal. Mach das mal. Mach das mal.
Es ist ja nicht so, alles machst du einfach mal gut.
Du machst mal kurz Google auf und sagst, ah, easy.
Das ist wirklich ein hübsches Sümmchen, möchte ich mal so behaupten.
Ja, aber natürlich ist das etwas mehr als das,
was wir jetzt hier in diesem Video überhaupt klären können, was das ist.
Nehmen wir aber einfach mal die Idee, ihr wollt Google hacken.
Ihr habt gesehen, Mensch, man darf jetzt Google eingreifen.
Ihr wollt Google hacken.
Also, was machen wir? Wir wollen Google hacken.
Und dazu müssen wir dann schon überlegen, was gehört denn eigentlich alles dazu?
Google ist eine Website.
Das heißt, wir müssen uns mit Webentwicklung beschäftigen.
Wir müssen uns damit beschäftigen...
Der echte Proxy, was meinste?
Wenn ihr irgendwas eingebt, das heißt, ihr müsst erst mal selbst vielleicht überlegen,
was ist denn eigentlich eine Website?
Was macht das Ding denn überhaupt aus?
Also, der 0815 Hacker findet keine Remote-Code-Execution irgendwie bei Google.
Ist einfach so, ja.
Kann ich eine Website kaputt kriegen?
Und dann könnt ihr überhaupt erst mal dran denken,
irgendwie eine Schwachstelle in einer Web anzunehmen.
Außer die zwei, die McDonalds gehackt haben.
Die haben es natürlich, die machen das.
Finden.
So, jetzt ist mir klar, dass das natürlich schon wieder etwas zu viel ist.
Aber zum Beispiel sagt Google euch...
Ey, muss ich mal kurz anhören.
Die einzige wirkliche Sicherheitslücke, die ich bisher gefunden habe,
weil ich danach gesucht habe,
ist in einer Firmware von einer Kamera,
wo man das Root-Passwort rauskriegen kann.
Ansonsten interessiert mich das Thema nicht sonderlich, also...
Ja.
Hat jeder so Science.
Der Provokateur, fünf Monate, dankeschön.
Excellent subscription.
Das stand ganz unten dabei, was ihr machen dürft.
Also Cross-Site Scripting, Cross-Site Request Forgery,
Mixed Content Scripts,
Communication und Authorization Flaws,
Server-Site Code Execution Bugs und so weiter.
Das heißt, Google nimmt hier freiwillig die Position des Blue Teams ein
und gibt euch die Freikarte, das Red Team zu sein.
Ich hab dafür gar nichts bekommen.
Ich hab eine neue Firma bekommen, wo es gefixt ist.
Ein halbes Jahr später.
Hab ich euch...
Da sind wir gerade beim Thema Hexhorn.
Hab ich euch das mal erzählt?
Mit der Kamera und dem Root-Passwort?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Kurze Story dazu.
Ich hatte mir eine Kamera gekauft.
Und hier, von diesem Hersteller.
Kann ich jetzt mal zeigen, ist aber egal.
Gab's im Angebot bei Amazon.
Nicht sonderlich bekannt hier von denen.
Hat ich mir eine Kamera bestellt.
Gab's im Angebot...
So eine kleine hier war das.
Ich glaub, sowas hier.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Hatt ich mir mal bestellt.
Und...
Irgendwie sieht der Dark-Reader ziemlich kacke aus auf der Seite.
Wobei ansonsten hier blendet es sich ja.
Zumindest hab ich die Kamera eingesteckt.
Und hab festgestellt, okay.
Kann alles, was ich haben will.
Also sprich, du kannst was drehen übers Web-Interface.
Das Ding an RTSP-Stream.
Low-Quality, High-Quality, alles gut.
Und irgendwann hab ich mich gefragt.
Das ist merkwürdig, dass es Vorschau-Bilder gibt.
Also warum gibt es Vorschau-Bilder?
Weil normalerweise muss ich um den RTSP-Stream,
um den Videostream aufzumachen.
Muss ich Username und Passwort eingeben.
Sagt, warum hab ich vor...
Oder warum kann ich mir Vorschau-Bilder von der Kamera angucken?
Ohne dass ich das Passwort weiß.
So, und dann...
Hab ich mal ein bisschen nachgeguckt.
Und hab festgestellt.
Diese Kamera unterstützt was, das nennt sich...
So.
Das ist irgendein Standard zum Steuern von Kameras.
Also immer.
Da wusste ich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt gar nicht, dass es das gibt.
Und da hab ich geguckt, wie der Kram funktioniert.
Das ist im Prinzip...
XML.
Jede Menge...
Also jede Menge HTTP-Requests mit XML drinne.
Und man kann...
Es gibt in diesem Protokoll hier...
So eine Art Discover-Modus.
Wo man quasi...
Die Kamera fragen kann, was kannst du alles?
Und wenn man...
Den passenden Curl aufruft...
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Kann ich euch nämlich auch zeigen, wie das Ganze...
Wie das Ganze funktioniert.
You're just...
Here...
View.
Genau.
Das hier war der Request, den ich geschickt hab.
Das hier, ich hab's wieder gefunden.
Warum mach ich das hier auf?
Also das ist der Request, den ich geschickt hab an die Kamera.
Das ist dieses Discover-Zeugs.
Das da.
Das ist der Request, den man an die Kamera schicken muss.
Man sieht jede Menge XML-Geschiss innen drinne.
Also sprich, was man an die Kamera schickt, ist...
Das ist die Adresse von der Kamera.
Man macht ein Postrequest an die Kamera.
Und...
Sagt hier, es ist XML, blablabla, sonst was.
Und das ist halt der Inhalt von diesem Request.
Wo dann drinne steht, hier, gib mir die URL für Vorschaubilder.
Und das Interessante ist die Antwort.
Das Interessante ist die Antwort...
Die man bekommt von der Kamera.
Und zwar ist die Antwort von der Kamera das hier.
Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wer's sieht.
Jede Menge XML-Geschiss.
Alter, wie lang ist denn der Kack?
XML, please!
Monka XML.
What the fuck?
ETF.
Zumindest hier, guck da.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Habt ihr das erkannt?
Was da drin steht?
Ja.
Das kriegste unauthentifizierter als Antwort.
Und zwar, User, Route, Passwort, das da...
Also sprich, man kriegt in der Snapshot-Uhrl für Vorschaubilder...
In der Snapshot-Uhrl für Vorschaubilder kriegt man quasi gleich das Route-Passwort mitgeliefert.
Exzellent.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich schlecht.
Und deswegen haben auch die Vorschaubilder funktioniert, weil die Vorschaubilder das Route-Passwort dran hatten.
Wie bist du darauf gestoßen?
Ja, weil ich mich gewundert hab, warum ich Vorschaubilder hab.
Und dann hab ich halt ein bisschen ausprobiert.
So, das ist meine einzige krasse Hexor-Erfahrung, die ich bisher gemacht hab.
Dann kann ich endlich mal diesen Step-by-Step-Guide anfangen, nachdem ich euch schon wieder zugeschwallert hab, mit was es alles gibt.
Es gibt erstmal Grundlagen, die man auf allen Seiten, also auf Blueteam und Redteam, können muss.
Und was kann man damit machen?
Na ja, als Admin auf die Kamera zugreifen, was man normalerweise nicht haben möchte.
Also man bekommt das Admin-Passwort raus für die Kamera, ohne dass man halt selbst sich authentifizieren muss.
Ansonsten kann man halt nicht wirklich viel bewirken.
Und das ist einfach mal Linux, Python programmieren, Grundlagen der Netzwerktechnik und virtuelle Maschinen, würde ich jetzt so behaupten.
Das ist für mich irgendwie was.
Das würde ich so unterschreiben.
Das ist wirklich gut.
Also, an Linux kommst du nicht vorbei.
An Grundlagen Netzwerktechnik kommst du auch nicht vorbei.
An Grundlagen Netzwerktechnik, inklusive wie HTTP und sowas, da kommst du nicht vorbei.
VMS kommst du auch nicht dran vorbei.
Hier kann man sich jetzt ein bisschen drüber schreiben.
Ich würde sagen, man sollte prinzipiell ein bisschen programmieren können.
Python bietet sich an in vielen Bereichen, aber man sollte ein bisschen programmieren können.
Die Sprache, würde ich sagen, ist gar nicht mal so extrem wichtig.
Wie weit geht Grundlagen Netzwerktechnik?
Ja, du solltest wissen, lass mal überlegen.
Du solltest wissen, wie ein Router funktioniert.
Du solltest wissen, was HTTP macht.
Was passiert, wenn Rechner A mit Rechner B kommunizieren will, also die einzelnen Schritte.
Vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen, wie HTTP-Authentifizierung funktioniert.
Grundlagen, so die Unterschiede zwischen TCP, UDP, ICMP.
Wie werden Ports ausgewählt?
An welchen Stellen gibt es irgendwelche Check-Summen?
Ja, Grundlagen.
Du musst halt wissen, wie die Kommunikation zwischen dir und deiner Webseite zum Beispiel abläuft.
Aber das würde ich exakt so unterschreiben.
Dann kann ich nirgends Pentas...
Ist ICMP nicht in TCP?
Nein.
Tatsächlich ist Linux einfach essenziell, weil über 90% der Web-Server, das heißt da, wo die Webseiten drauf laufen,
auch über Linux läuft.
Und wenn ihr Erfahrung mit Linux habt, dann könnt ihr das natürlich einfach auch darauf übertragen.
Das heißt, wenn ihr wisst, wie Linux funktioniert, dann wisst ihr auch automatisch, wie eigentlich Web-Server intern funktionieren.
Und da kann man dann natürlich hergehen und sich einfach kostenlos ein Linux bei sich installieren
und einfach dieses Ding verwenden und tatsächlich mal ein bisschen benutzen.
Machen wir ja jeden Stream in Linux verwenden.
Ich würde mich nicht nur einfach hingehen und eine virtuelle Maschine machen, das machen sehr, sehr viele.
Ich empfehle tatsächlich mal Windows wirklich wegzulassen und Linux als Hauptbetriebssystem...
Ja, okay. Ja, ja, ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Es ist nicht schlecht, wenn man sich dann mal zwangsläufig mit Linux auseinandersetzen muss.
Aber ich meine, ich verwende auf der Arbeit den ganzen Tag Linux.
Ich nehme jetzt raus, mich dafür entscheiden zu können, zu sagen, hey, ich verwende privat Windows für Spiele und Krams hier und eine Linux VM.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, sich mal wirklich ein paar Monate rein mit Linux auseinanderzusetzen,
weil man dann eben bei vielen Sachen auch die Probleme selber lösen muss.
Und leider ist es unter Linux halt an vielen Stellen ein extremes Gefrickel, wenn Sachen nicht sofort funktionieren.
Warum? Was, was, was macht denn im Hintergrund irgendwelche komischen Installer oder so?
Muss ich gerade mal kurz gucken. Und dementsprechend lernt man da halt auch viel bei.
Okay, laufen keine Installer. Der NVIDIA Web Helper macht Dinger, was auch immer.
Also euch wirklich dazu zu zwingen, Linux zu verwenden, denn dort werdet ihr dann automatisch an die Materie rangeführt.
Python programmieren ist einfach was, es ist einfach normal in der Hackerwelt, sage ich jetzt einfach mal.
Das stimmt.
Oder generell in der IT Welt, dass Dinge, die nicht automatisch funktionieren.
Es ist sau viel, es ist sau viel in Python.
Gerade auch wenn man im Bereich, sag ich mal, was gibt es da, Machine Learning und sowas jetzt unterwegs ist, mal was anderes,
was unabhängig von diesem ganzen Hack-Sort-Thema ist. Python ist aktuell eine der gefragtesten oder der verbreitetsten
und in Hype-Technologien meist verwendeten Sprachen zurzeit, die es gibt.
Eine gewisse Zeit Nut oder brauchen, die müssen automatisiert werden und dazu benutzt man einfach Python.
Ihr werdet wahrscheinlich, wenn ihr eure ersten Hacks schreibt, in Anführungsstrichen,
werdet ihr wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt Python verwenden, um Hacks zu schreiben,
sondern ihr werdet Python benutzen, um euch quasi ein Skript zu schreiben, das dann den Hack ausführt.
Welche Vorabendien ich benutze?
Vor allem bei Workstation.
Damit ihr das nicht hunderttausendmal...
Leute, wenn ihr Fragen habt, müsst ihr wirklich entwupplos dabei schreiben,
weil ich gucke jetzt gerade das Video und ich sehe es im Chat manchmal nicht so.
Aber ich logge das hier ja mit. Ich logge ja die Fragen mit.
Welche Vorabendien ist, wie gesagt, vor allem bei Workstation?
Ähm...
Hi, wie ist das bei LO gegenüber Embers Office?
Was?
Libro Office. Libro Office ist scheiße.
Aber Microsoft Office ist auch nicht viel besser.
Ich verwende überhaupt kein Office Zeugs.
Das einzige Programm, das ganze Office Zeug, was da Daseinsberechtigung hat, ist Excel.
So für die ganzen Stonks Spreadsheet-Leute.
Was ist deine Meinung zu WSL, vor allem im Vergleich zu einer VM?
VM besser.
WSL hakt an vielen Stellen.
Von Hand machen müsst, weil ihr sonst mehrere Jahre an einem Pentest dran sitzt.
Und das dauert einfach viel zu lange.
Und da gibt es auch wirklich gute Quellen, was man da machen kann.
Nicht zuletzt meinen Kanal. Bitte einmal ganz kurz reingucken.
Kommen wir aber nachher noch dazu.
So, dann gibt es natürlich noch die Netzwerktechnik.
Das stimmt.
Normalerweise werde ich nicht irgendwas bei euch auf dem Rechner angreifen.
Das ist allgemein eines der wichtigsten Sachen überhaupt.
Das hilft einem auch unglaublich, wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert, rauszubekommen, wo es nicht funktioniert.
Man muss den Wireshark ordentlich bedienen können.
Das ist das Erste, was man lernt.
TCP-Dump mitschneiden, dann Wireshark sich die ganze Sache angucken.
So ein bisschen Grundlagen. Wireshark muss auf jeden Fall sein.
Sonst kommt man nicht weit.
Dadurch, wenn man weiß, wie die Netzwerkkommunikation tut.
Also sprich von lokal, vom APRI-Quest bis über dein Gateway.
Und dann irgendwie noch ein DNS dazwischen.
Dann machst du ein HTTP, dass du weißt, dass HTTP get, post, put, was auch immer noch alles gibt.
Das hilft einem unglaublich, rauszukriegen, oftmals wo Probleme sind.
Aber man muss wissen, wie man Portscans mit Nmap macht.
Ja, so Zeug.
Was ist das Problem mit Word oder PowerPoint?
Gar nicht, aber ich finde es total überflüssig.
Ich finde es einfach nur eklig, eklig zu bedienen.
Wobei das neue PowerPoint, ich musste jetzt ja letztens eine PowerPoint-Präsentation machen, oder sogar zwei.
Das neue PowerPoint geht halbwegs.
Aber wie gesagt, ich mache alles, sofern es geht, irgendwie in Markdown und dann als PDF.
Markdown PDF, gut ist.
Wie kommen eigentlich meine Pakete, die ich hier gerade an meinem PC habe, also wie kommen diese Daten eigentlich ins Internet?
Und das eröffnet schon wieder alles so einen riesigen Rattenschwanz hinter Netzwerktechnik.
Da werdet ihr früher oder später wahrscheinlich noch in die Anonymität im Internet reinfallen und so weiter und so fort.
Und ja, virtuelle Maschinen, das ist einfach nur wichtig, dass ihr da wisst, wie man damit umgeht,
damit ihr auch tatsächlich nachher bei euch ein bisschen üben könnt auf dem Rechner.
Da komme ich gleich noch dazu.
Es ist viel komplizierter, als man manchmal so denkt.
Allein schon, wenn du zwei Raspberry Pis nebeneinanderstehen an einem Switch.
Beide haben eine IP aus dem gleichen Netz.
Allein schon, wie es dort funktioniert, dass, sagen wir mal, ein Ping von A nach B kommt.
Das können dir die meisten Leute nicht sagen.
Das ist so das einfachste Szenario überhaupt.
Zwei Rechner nebeneinander im gleichen Netz, Ping von A nach B.
Was passiert da in welcher Reihenfolge?
Das wissen die meisten Leute schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Ihr werdet es nicht glauben, 90% der Leute, die in der IT arbeiten, wissen das nicht.
Fragt den 0815-Windows-Admin.
Der hat keinen Schimmer.
Der weiß das nicht.
Wo man sagen würde, hey, das ist doch eigentlich gar kein Problem.
Die vergessen nämlich einen ganz entscheidenden Schritt oftmals.
Weil man das meistens nicht braucht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Meistens funktioniert das.
Aber es ist trotzdem wichtig zu wissen, falls man nicht funktioniert.
Weil der Chat sich da gerade dran versucht.
Der Router ist schon mal vollkommen egal, wenn die Rechner lokal sind und im gleichen Netz stehen.
Da macht ein Router nichts.
Da kann ein Router auch gar nichts machen.
Das Wichtigste ist, was die meisten Leute vergessen, ist eigentlich der ARP-Request.
Wahrscheinlich werden sich jetzt 90% der Leute im Chat egal was zum Teufeln, das ist ein ARP-Request.
ARP-Request ist das Ding, was eine IP-Adresse auflöst zu einer MAC-Adresse.
Und das ist das Entscheidende, wo viele Leute schon mal komplett vergessen.
Dass das ohne eigentlich gar nicht geht.
Weil die eigentliche Kommunikation ist ja nicht TCP, ist nicht IP, ist nicht ICMP.
Die eigentliche Kommunikation unten drunter ist Ethernet.
Also sprich, wenn man auf OSI-Geschichten steht, Layer 2.
Und Ethernet, wenn man sich so einen Frame anguckt, die Adressierung geht über MAC-Adressen.
Das heißt, was du machen musst ist, du musst die IP-Adresse zu einer MAC-Adresse auflösen.
Du musst quasi einen Request broadcasten ins Netzwerk, wo drin steht, ey, IP-Adresse Punkt 1, sag mal deine MAC.
So, und nur wenn du die MAC-Adresse hast, dann kannst du einem über Ethernet auch was zustellen.
Und das ist der Schritt, den ganz viele Leute einfach nicht wissen, dass der existiert oder dass der notwendig ist oder sonst was.
Das ist übrigens auch das, wie das mit dem Router und Gateway funktioniert.
Weil überlegt euch mal, wie kommt eigentlich euer Paket zu Google hin?
Oder wie kommt euer Paket aus eurem lokalen Netzwerk raus?
Die sagen alle, ja, okay, ganz klar, an den Router schicken.
Aber was bedeutet es denn, an den Router zu schicken?
Weil die Ziel-IP muss ja nach wie vor die IP von einem Google-Server sein.
In dem IP-Paket steht drin, Ziel-IP, sag mal 8888, Absender-IP, meine.
Wie kommt dieses Paket zum Router?
Die Router-IP taucht in dem ganzen Ding nicht auf.
Wie kommt das Ding zum Router? Ganz einfach.
Das stellt, guckt nach, aha, das Ziel ist nicht in meinem lokalen Netzwerk.
Macht ein Apri-Quest an die Router-IP.
Und das IP-Package selbst steht nichts von der Router-IP drin.
Das Einzige, was passiert ist, dass ein Apri-Quest geschickt wird.
Die Router-IP wird aufgelöst zur Mac-Adresse vom Interface, vom Router.
Und ihr schickt den Ethernet-Frame an den Router.
Das IP-Paket innen drin hat mit dem Router überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Also das sind so Sachen, die gerade wenn man dann gucken will,
wo was nicht richtig funktioniert oder vielleicht wo auch Schwachstellen drin sind,
da muss man schon wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Und es reicht auch, wenn man weiß, dass es sowas gibt und im Zweifelsfall nachgucken kann.
Also man muss das nicht komplett aus dem Kopf wissen.
Es ist aber wichtig, dass man weiß, dass es sowas gibt und dass man dann nachgucken kann.
Ich hätte jetzt auch keinen Plassen Schimmer, wie so ein Apri-Quest eigentlich genau aussieht,
aber wenn du weißt, dass es sowas gibt, dann guckst du einfach bei Wikipedia
und das steht dann da drin.
Aber dazu musst du erst mal wissen, dass es sowas gibt.
Fachinformatik-Abschlussprüfer-Vormereitung.
Ja, hatten wir doch letztens von.
Kann mir mal jemand sagen, was Latex ist?
Ja, kann ich dir sagen.
Das ist sowas wie HTML, bloß für Zeichensetzungen.
Also quasi eine Beschreibungssprache, sowas wie HTML im Endeffekt,
wo es halt ums korrekte Layouten und Setzen von Zeichen geht.
Murphymo8 sagt hallo, moin.
Ich habe schon gedacht, ich habe wieder einen übersehen.
All diese Techniken hier, egal was euch irgendwelche Menschen erzählen,
ich habe da schon einen komischen Flyer gesehen in Amerika tatsächlich,
aber tatsächlich sind das alles samt keine Hacker-Techniken.
Das ist einfach etwas, das benutzen normale...
Oh, ich habe uns übersehen hier.
Der Provokateur, 5 Monate, poggers.
Und MattKai hat resubscribed, für 11 Monate habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Excellent Subscription, Dankeschön.
Huge.
Darkreader.
Das benutzen Server-Administratoren, das benutzen alle Menschen.
Das hat mit krassen Hacksorgen gar nichts zu tun, das stimmt.
Zumindest viele, sagen wir mal viele.
Und das ist trotzdem allerdings eine Grundlage.
Man muss sich sozusagen erst mal ein grundlegendes Wissen aufbauen,
bevor man...
Wenigstens mal ein gescheites Video zum Thema.
...hacking überhaupt anfangen kann.
Und ihr seht, hier ist jetzt bewusst noch keine Web-Entwicklung oder sowas hingeschrieben worden,
denn das kommt jetzt.
Wenn ihr die Grundlagen habt, dann müsst ihr natürlich erst mal eigene Dinge produzieren.
Das heißt, eigene Software entwickeln.
Ihr seht, ein Hacker kann auch Software entwickeln.
Und das ist eigentlich so der große Punkt.
Hacker können genauso Software entwickeln wie Software-Entwickler.
Nur sie denken danach ein bisschen anders.
Sie wollen danach das Ding kaputt kriegen.
Die meisten Hacker sind schlichter kein Software-Entwickler, würde ich mal sagen.
Irgendwie zum Absturz bringen, irgendwie dazu bringen, Dinge zu tun, die sie nicht tun sollen.
Also wenn ihr zum Beispiel in einem Spiel...
Nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal irgendeinen Browser...
Oder nehmen wir nicht ein Browser-Game, sondern nehmen wir ein richtiges Spiel.
Wenn ihr in einem Spiel testet, hey, kann ich mich da hochglitschen?
Kann ich vielleicht das Spiel dazu bringen, dass es Dinge tut, die es eigentlich nicht tun soll?
Dann ist das schon mal so das erste Hacker-Denken.
Und Hacker machen das im Endeffekt mit allem.
Also die machen das mit Webseiten.
Die machen das eben mit auch Anwendungen, mit Apps und so weiter und so fort.
Und danach, wenn ihr die geschrieben habt und kaputt gekriegt habt,
dann müsst ihr sie natürlich reparieren, damit ihr wisst, was da kaputt gegangen ist.
Und sie natürlich erweitern.
Und ja, das...
Und da kommt dazu, dass es mittlerweile super ist, dass es sowas wie GitHub gibt.
Und es tausend Sachen gibt, die man sich anschauen kann.
Hat ja auch gerade einer im Chat geschrieben.
Gerade wenn man einsteigt, sei es irgendwie, wenn man eine neue Programmiersprache lernt,
wenn man ein neues Framework lernt, wenn man irgendwelche neuen Sachen lernt,
ist es super, sich mal anzugucken, wie das Leute verwenden, die schon ein bisschen Ahnung davon haben.
Da lernt man richtig viel von.
Könnt ihr, wie gesagt, nicht nur machen mit Webseiten, sondern auch mit Apps, mit normalen Anwendungen...
Und ich meine damit nicht, sich jetzt den Code von einer Webseite hier irgendwie anzugucken.
Das ist ja meistens Minifighter-Crap.
Da erkennst du ja schon mal gar nichts, ja.
Ähm, nein, the fuck.
Sondern sich den Source Code angucken auf GitHub von Projekten, die halt zu dem passen, was man machen will.
Mit Skripten, mit Kommandozeilen, Argumenten und so weiter und so fort.
All diese Dinge könnt ihr da ausprobieren.
Und ja, wenn ihr das alles schon gemacht habt, dann fällt das hier auch unter zweitens, und zwar die Techniken lernen.
Dann könnt ihr tatsächlich euch eins dieser Gebiete aussuchen und dort mal ein bisschen genauer hingucken.
Und vielleicht findet ihr dann interessante Gebiete, wie zum Beispiel Schwachstellen finden, die euch faszinieren.
Und da könnt ihr dann einfach noch ein bisschen tiefer reingehen.
Einfach mal nach diesen Bedingungen dann auch suchen und sich dann auch selber damit beschäftigen.
Aber immer mit diesem Hintergrund eures Projekts.
Das heißt, ihr habt zum Beispiel eine Web-Anwendung geschrieben, ja.
Dann müsst ihr nicht irgendwie Schwachstellen von Android-Apps suchen, denn ihr habt keine Android-App geschrieben.
Ihr solltet dann Schwachstellen von Web-Anwendungen suchen.
Das ist eh so was, wo ich sag, das ist bei allem gut.
Wenn man ein gewisses Problem lösen will, dann hat man auch einen gewissen inneren Antrieb weiterzumachen.
Also sprich, wenn man jetzt sagen will, alter, ich wollte schon, keine Ahnung, mir geht die Software, die es in diesem Bereich gibt, voll auf den Sack, ich bastel mal was Eigenes.
Dann hat man einen gewissen Antrieb dahinter, dass man das mal fertig kriegt.
Das ist ja das Problem, was ich auch oft hab.
Ich fange immer übelst motiviert mit irgendwelchen, ihr kennt's, ihr kennt mich, ja.
Mittlerweile haben wir schon viele Sachen im Stream angefangen.
Und während ich dann so am Programmieren bin, verlier ich oftmals das Interesse an dem Thema und mach dann halt nie weiter.
Aber halt, solange ich Interesse an dem Thema hab, wird da halt jeden Tag dann rumgebastelt.
Und dann euch darüber informieren.
Ihr solltet dann wirklich Exploits entwickeln, die für Web-Anwendungen gedacht sind.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Und ja, ebenfalls unter zweitens, und ihr seht, es ist quasi...
Wie oft, wie oft kommt denn da noch zweitens?
Wir hatten jetzt das vierte Mal zweitens.
Zeitig, verfallen Übungen.
Das heißt, ihr macht natürlich nicht nur euer Projekt, sondern ihr macht auch Projekte von anderen kaputt.
Und es gibt Websites, da dürft ihr legal hacken üben.
Es gibt Challenges, es gibt CTFs, also Capture the Flag Games, das sind wirklich Spiele.
Und es gibt War Games.
Und all diese Dinge könnt ihr gratis und meistens absolut gefahrlos, das heißt meistens normalerweise immer gefahrlos, eigentlich bei euch nutzen.
Und dann auch versuchen da irgendwie einzudringen und das Ding kaputt zu machen.
Und wenn ihr das tatsächlich gemacht habt, dann seid ihr, spätestens dann seid ihr absolut so weit wie jeder Hacker.
Gibt's auch Battle Royale, genau.
Kommt als nächstes.
Ihr seid dann in einem Bereich drin und dort habt ihr ein bisschen Expertise euch angehäuft sozusagen.
Und dann geht es nur noch darum, wirklich zu üben, Neues zu lernen und von vorne das ganze wiederzumachen.
Das heißt, ihr arbeitet euch von jetzt in Webentwicklung mit PHP ein.
Und dann öffnet ihr das nächste Tor.
Dann sagt ihr, okay, jetzt will ich wissen, wie es im Frontend aussieht.
Das heißt, ihr arbeitet euch in HTML, CSS, JavaScript ein.
Dann arbeitet ihr euch in Python ein, Python Flask, Python Django.
Dann arbeitet ihr euch in Java Swing ein und so weiter und so fort.
Jedes Mal merkt ihr, ah, okay, das kann da eigentlich schief gehen.
Das kann da verputt gehen.
Hier kann ich vielleicht eine Schwachstelle finden und so weiter und so fort.
Und dadurch habt ihr natürlich automatisch immer mehr Wissen und könnt dann immer besser...
Deswegen, das sind Sachen, die ihn interessieren, gehe ich jetzt mal von aus.
Deswegen, ich bin auch der Ansicht, es ist wirklich gut, wenn man sich die Sachen eben raussucht, die einen interessieren.
Wenn man PHP mag, warum nicht? Ja, wenn man Java mag, warum nicht?
Man kann sich allerdings genauso gut.NET-Geschichten angucken im Backend.
Ein JavaScript, CSS, HTML kommt man eh nicht vorbei.
Java ist natürlich insofern ganz praktisch, weil das meiste Enterprise, Bankenzeug, Java ist...
Zumindest das zum Frontend hin.
Aber halt, je nachdem, was einen interessiert.
Systeme eindringen.
Und ja, natürlich, wenn ihr irgendwo merkt, ihr trefft auf irgendwas, wo ihr nicht mehr weiterkommt, dann sucht ihr danach.
So einfach ist das.
So, jetzt habe ich sehr viel gesagt, was ihr lernen wollt.
Man googelt eh noch ein Prozent der Zeit.
Das ist quasi jetzt der Step-by-Step-Guide.
Ihr müsst wirklich extrem viel lernen und dieser ganze Prozess, der dauert wirklich Jahre.
Also wenn ihr euch da nicht genug Zeit gebt, dann wird das nicht funktionieren.
Das heißt, ihr müsst wirklich einrechnen, allein zu programmieren.
Oder damit ihr wirklich vernünftig programmieren könnt oder vernünftig eine Website entwickeln könnt, müsst ihr wirklich schon mehrere Jahre fast schon einplanen.
Das heißt, das ist wirklich ein Prozess.
Ihr fangt an in die IT rein zu drücken.
Und deswegen geht das auch nur, wenn man sich dafür interessiert.
Das Einzige, was sich ändert zu einem normalen Informatiker, ist euer Mindset.
Ihr wollt Dinge kaputt machen und sie danach wieder zusammensetzen.
Ähnlich wie bei Lego, könnte man sagen.
Manche Menschen bauen Lego nur auf. Das sind die ganz normalen Informatiker.
Manche Menschen bauen Lego auf, zerstören sie und bauen sie danach besser auf.
Das sind die Hacker.
Also ich habe mit Lego immer andere Sachen zusammengebaut, als das Set wollte.
Das soll jetzt nicht abwertend klingen gegenüber normalen Informatikern.
Ich mache hier gerade mit meinen Händen diese Anführungsstriche, die ihr nicht sehen könnt.
Das ist definitiv nicht abwertend gedacht, sondern das ist einfach nur...
Man möchte noch ein Stückchen tiefer.
Man möchte gucken, wo kann ich denn dieses Gebäude eigentlich zum Einstürzen bringen.
Und ich will euch jetzt noch ganz kurz zeigen, wo ihr das eigentlich alles, zumindest zum Teil, lernen könnt.
Ihr findet hier auf meinem Kanal eigentlich hauptsächlich Zeugstassen Richtung Hacken gehen.
Und zwar wenn ihr da mal einfach durchscrollt, dann seht ihr, wir haben hier was mit Python gemacht.
Wir haben sogar Hacken mit Python gemacht, wobei ihr nicht nur diese Playlist hier gucken sollt.
Diese Playlist hier ist auf jeden Fall essentiell notwendig, wenn ihr irgendwas mit Python machen wollt.
Und dann könnt ihr da einfach immer tiefer reingehen.
Wenn ihr euch generell für Security interessiert, dann geht ihr hier auf diesen Bereich.
Und Achtung, hier drüben hat es immer diese kleinen Pfeile.
Da geht es noch weiter.
Das sind alles Dinge, die man wirklich können kann oder die man lernen kann.
Die man können kann, das ist richtig, ja.
Wenn man hier irgendwas mit Webentwicklung, d.h. Webseiten hacken möchte...
Es gibt viele Dinge, die man können kann.
Dann sollte man sich natürlich auch angucken, wie eigentlich Webseiten überhaupt aufgebaut sind.
Und wenn ihr nicht euch anguckt, wie Webseiten aufgebaut sind, dann könnt ihr natürlich auch keine Webseiten hacken.
Denn ihr wollt ja im Endeffekt...
Aber die meisten Sachen können andere können. Ja, richtig.
... kaputt machen, die andere Menschen aufgebaut haben.
Und diese Menschen können Webseiten entwickeln.
D.h. ihr müsst wirklich fast besser sein als diese Menschen.
D.h. wenn ihr Google hacken wollt, müsst ihr besser sein als die Entwickler bei Google.
Die meisten Leute werden auf Google nix nix hacken.
Und ich... also...
Ich finde das Video wirklich gut.
Ja, also das ist eines der wenigen Videos, die ich bisher gesehen habe, wo ich das fast alles unterschreiben könnte.
Aber in manchen Bereichen hat man halt vielleicht ein bisschen andere Ansichten.
Ich denke, die Frage, wer besser ist oder schlechter, stellt sich da gar nicht so sehr.
Die besten Programmierer bauen auch mal Scheiße, weil sie nicht aufpassen.
Und das passiert bei Google auch.
Und gerade im Bereich von Business-Anwendungen glaubt man gar nicht, wie viel Scheiße da programmiert wird, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Und...
D.h. da kann man durchaus auch was finden an manchen Stellen, wo die Leute nicht aufgepasst.
Da bin ich mir sicher. Wie gesagt, ich bin in dem Bereich überhaupt nicht drin.
Aber nachdem überall permanent Scheiße gebaut wird, besteht auch die Chance, überall permanent Scheiße zu finden.
Weil wenn es danach geht, dürfte es ja beispielsweise Linux auch überhaupt keine Schwachstellen mehr geben.
Weil du kannst von ausgehen, dass zumindest die Core-Contributor-Leute für den Linux-Kernel somit die besten C-Programmierer sind, die du auf der Welt findest.
Und trotzdem gibt es genug Leute, die dort immer mal wieder irgendwelche Schwachstellen finden.
Und auch die besten Programmierer bauen mal Scheiße. Ist einfach so.
Baust du auch Scheiße beim Programmieren? Ja klar, musst ja nur mal ins Stream angucken, aber...
Es ist auch so unfassbar schwer, besser zu sein als all diese Gehirne, die hinter Google zusammenarbeiten.
Aber wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel eure Website hacken wollt, an der vielleicht nur ihr gearbeitet habt, dann ist das durchaus möglich.
Denn ihr verbessert euch jedes Mal, wenn ihr ein Video anguckt, jedes Mal, wenn ihr irgendwas programmiert.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ihr ein CTF macht, jedes Mal, wenn ihr ein, I don't know, Game spielt, in dem es ein kleines bisschen in Richtung anderes denken geht.
Eine Sache, die mir auch noch dazu einfällt, die halt auch zu Fehlern führen können, ist, dass man halt versucht, besonders clever zu sein.
Das kommt manchmal vor. Man sagt, wir können doch diesen Teil weglassen, dann ist die Performance besser, dann ist der Code einfacher, dann ist irgendwas anders.
Und man vergisst halt dann, dass das doch nicht sinnlos war, dass es diesen Code-Teil gegeben hat.
Ich erinnere nur mal an die Random-Geschichte und die es unter Debian gegeben hat.
Return 5.
Das ist Jahre her, aber das fand ich super.
Was ist denn der Comic dazu? Debian Return 5, genau.
Der da, der ist gut.
Also, die hatten unter Debian mal, ich glaube, in OpenSSL war es.
Ich glaube, es war OpenSSL. Es kann sein, Disclaimer, es kann sein, dass ich das ein bisschen durcheinander bringe.
Die hatten in OpenSSL, haben die einfach was auskommentiert, weil der Programmierer gedacht hatte, ich glaube, der war sogar von der Telekom der Programmierer damals.
Aber nagelte mich jetzt nicht drauf fest, es könnte auch was anderes gewesen sein.
Haben sie irgendwas auskommentiert und dann war es am Ende so, also nach dem Motto, überflüssiger Code auskommentiert.
Und dann war es am Ende so, dass von, ich sag jetzt mal, Billionen möglichen Key-Kombinationen es am Ende, glaube ich, noch 65.000 oder so gab.
Was dann halt dazu geführt hat, dass es erstmal massig Kollisionen gegeben hat und sich alle gefragt haben, hä, was ist hier los?
Und halt auch die ganzen Keys nicht sicher waren.
Und dann haben die halt diesen Comic rausgebracht, wo einer gesagt hat, okay, wir ersetzen einfach unsere Random-Funktion durch Return 4.
Also, und das sind bestimmt keine Noobs gewesen, ja?
Aber ja, es sind alle alles Dinge für Probleme finden, all diese Dinge findet ihr. Auch C und C++, C-Sharp und so.
Also, ja, okay, geh mal fort, C++ der Teufel, äh.
Game-Engines sind für euch relevant, Java ist natürlich für euch relevant, theoretische Informatik ist auch sehr wichtig,
Algorithmen sind unfassbar relevant für jeden Hacker, Kryptographie, Netzwerk-Technik, all diese Dinge, das ist absolut überwältigend.
Guckt euch, fällt mir noch an, habt ihr die letzte Sudolücke mitgekriegt?
Wo man an sudo einfach nur irgendwas dran hängen muss und verruht solche dinger das sind keine nupes die das programmieren aber
Die größten pros bauen scheiße. Ich gebe ich absolut zu und wer wirklich
Sich mit hacken beschäftigen möchte und das ernst meint der muss da leider tatsächlich reingehen aber wie gesagt
Ich muss nicht alles lernen wenn ihr eine website hacken wollt dann müsst ihr nicht lernen wie c funktioniert oder wie linux intern
funktioniert also die
internen
Funktionen von linux
Oder ihr müsst nicht wissen wie man eine android app programmiert was ich hier gezeigt habe oder koteln können sondern ihr müsst eigentlich
Los ja war noch mehr er mag ja war also das habe ich schon mal festgestellt
Da haben wir komplett unterschiedliche ansichten er mag ja war ich mag ja war ich möchte webseiten programmieren ich will
Webseiten programmieren können und ich will sie danach wieder kaputt machen und so ist das eigentlich bei allem
Ja wirklich immer reingehen und immer mehr sich reinarbeiten frameworks verwenden und so weiter und so fort und das ist das
Eigentliches ziel das eigentlich jeder hacker von euch auch verfolgen sollte immer mehr reingehen immer mehr finden und immer mehr lernen
Ja und ja dementsprechend und dadurch dass man immer mehr lernt beziehungsweise dass man die motivation immer mehr zu lernen muss es halt was sein was
Ein interessiert geht gar anders
Niemand kann alles und ja ich natürlich auch nicht keine sorge und ihr werdet auch nicht alles das macht mir schon mal sehr sympathisch
Und ich wünsche euch ganz viel behauptet er hat den kompletten durchblick hat keine ahnung wir hören uns beim nächsten mal wieder bis dann
Mir ist auch klar dass ich von
99 prozent der sachen keine ahnung habe und ein prozent der sachen vielleicht ganz ganz gut hinbekommen
Ja
Warum magst du ja war nicht ich habe nichts gegen java
Ich flay mir ja war nur immer ganz gerne war ein bisschen
Ich habe letztens übrigens auch ein fehler gemacht
Ich habe meinem chef gesagt kann java programmieren
Oder gesagt was du kannst ja war programmiert hat alle
Ich krieg das hin ist es nicht so dass ich das machen will
Ja
Hat er sich wahrscheinlich schon gleich gedacht aber endlich wir brauchen ja immer mehr leute die aber können
Ich habe dann aber gleich hinterher gesagt ich will da überhaupt nichts mit machen
Ich überlege gerade der letzte sudo root exploit der war richtig easy
Du musstest einfach ja genau
Ja genau man muss man muss die user id minus eins angeben genau das
Man musste einfach user id minus eins angeben und hinten dran dann befehle und dann hatte man root rechte mit der mit der passenden sudo version
Das war echt
Wieder richtig fail und wie gesagt die leute das programmieren das sind keine noobs ja
Aber auch die bauen scheiße und das war neun jahre neun oder zehn jahre war das in sudo drin
Hier ist der heiße artikel zu genau den können wir uns noch mal kurz angucken
Ah hier ist der heiße artikel zu genau den können wir uns noch mal kurz angucken
Ach nee das ist eine andere die meine ich gar nicht die meine ich gar nicht
Die meinte ich gar nicht ich meinte ich meinte die andere die mit dem minus eins
Aber wie gesagt daran sieht man das sind halt auch keine noobs und trotzdem bauen so scheiße so
So
Warum löscht so immer was aus der uhr das ist weil es meint ich habe so das ist so ein copy paste tick
Ja stimmt schon
Teil was teil togify schreibt kann ist ja an sich nicht mal scheiße gebaut sondern einfach nur nicht drüber nachgedacht ja nur nicht
Drüber nachgedacht ist halt oftmals der vorgänger von scheiße gebaut
Anders kann man es ja nicht nennen da wenn es wenn es neun jahre so einen easy root exploit in sudo gibt
Es ist schon scheiße gebaut aber ja es resultiert aus nicht richtig nachgedacht und umso komplexer die sache wird umso einfacher ist es
Ja auch was über was nicht nachzudenken oder an irgendwas nicht zu denken
Im prinzip ja im prinzip sagt er lernt alles
Und dementsprechend sind wir wieder bei dem eigentlichen thema was was ich ganz am anfang gesagt hat das war es an ihm interessieren
Das war es an ihm interessieren was was bin ich sehend was zum
Warum macht man solche videos
Was zum warum macht man solche videos
Da ist das hängen
Der fehlt jetzt noch
Das ist ja echt richtig dumm
Das ist echt richtig dumm
Okay was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten
Oh je das ist ein video da kann ich wieder meckern
Da kann ich wieder meckern
5 tools die windows 10 besser machen
Okay okay okay okay
Vielleicht auch nicht das video hat ziemlich gute bewertung vielleicht sind die auch gar nicht so schlecht
Nachschulibre neun monat dankeschön excellent subscription
Jetzt kommt schon cc cleaner
Und heute zeige ich euch 5 tools um praktische funktionen erweitern
ihr wisst ja armin und ich sind keine großen fans von extra software
Der armin ich kenn bloß den armin von der sendung mit der maus kennt ihr auch noch den armin
den christoph und den armin kennt ihr
Christoph und armin an die kann ich mich irgendwie noch erinnern
Zeug davon dass windows 10 von haus aus bereits sehr viele praktische funktion bietet
Vor allem wenn es zum beispiel um die optimierung geht
Wir zeigen auch regelmäßig wichtige tips auf unserem kanal also lasst auch gerne ein abo da
Also lasst auch gerne ein abo da
Können mittlerweile automatisch zwischen den designs umstellen abhängig davon ob es eben tag oder nacht ist
Krasse windows hacker hier am start
Das und einige weitere praktische funktionen und nachts um 21 Uhr das dunkel
Dabei lässt es sich natürlich auch konfigurieren wenn sich nur die apps an tag und nacht anpassen sollen
Und die tag geht das schon los ne oder somit einen hintergrund für den tag und einen für die nacht haben also wenn ihr tagsüber in starbucks arbeitet und in der nacht zu batman
Weshalb wir auto night oder cringe und nicht ein anderes program empfehlen das liegt einfach an der feinen programmierung
Die app ist open source und muss installiert werden aber sie überarbeitet nicht die registry erstellt keine einträge im explorer und das beste sie läuft nicht im hintergrund
Auto night mode verwendet nämlich den windows 10 integrierte aufgabenplanung einen dienst der sowieso auf jedem windows rechner läuft
Darüber wird der wechsel zwischen tag und nacht automatisiert sodass die app im hintergrund auch weder leistung noch strom zieht
Wir können auto night mode
Ich will wissen was die was was was empfehlt hat alles
Als von microsoft entwickelt wird die microsoft power toys sind ein
Ok das ist wirklich nicht schlecht das ist wirklich nicht schlecht
Der hat den gleichen hintergrund wie ich
Anzeige ist raus
Power toys ist wirklich gut
Zuerst unter windows 95 wieder findet müsst ihr diesen dateien einen sinnvollen namen ersetze ich einfach in dem fall power rename da ne sowas brauche ich nicht
Und viel effizienter arbeiten fast so als hätte dir da seht ihr dann verschiedene template
Das ist der das ist dieser teilen window manager light für windows
Und ihr ein größer links und rechts gleich zwei fenster oder einer werden will denn niemand von uns wurde als windows 10 profi geboren der sollte die
Ich finde ich finde es auch höchst suspekt wenn einer windows 10 profi ist
Power toys auf jeden fall installieren ihr könnt dann zum beispiel alles in der beschreibung das ist gut autodata power toys taskbar x das hatten wir uns das nicht mal
Angeguckt und move to desktop ok ich muss sagen die die tips scheinen nicht schlecht zu sein
Anlocker was auch immer der andere die tips scheinen nicht schlecht zu sein was mich überzeugt ist
Das sind open source github projekte die kann schon mal nicht richtig kacke sein
Center windows taskbar icons wird
Was macht das
Moment
Ah ja aber
Da trifft man die doch gar nicht mehr richtig aber da trifft man die buttons doch gar nicht mehr
Erst mal richtig schöne old school windows forms config da trifft man die icons doch gar nicht
Ok
Oh gibt es nicht mehr
Move to desktop von 2016
Ok das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch aber ich bin geht das geht das nicht so mittlerweile
Ach nee man muss das man muss das hier drüber machen
Hier drüber kann man das move
Ja
Ok das ist wahrscheinlich echt nicht schlecht
Das ist gar nicht übel ich habe nichts gesagt kann man kann man kann man so stehen lassen
Was was haben wir sonst noch hier java script history
Electronic arts will nur dein geld
Eine runde black ops 1
Das gucken wir nicht das frag einen millionär und den krassen hexer man kennst du die werbung noch
Nee aber die 27 minuten lang kann ich jetzt nicht nicht angucken
Den milliardär den milliardär ok wir gucken 15 minuten frag einen florian hom über den weg zu reichtum und die flucht vor dem fbi
Schauen wir mal
Den hexer gucken wir uns zum schluss an weil der wird 30 der wird 30 minuten wieder in seinen hecken wie die vom teufel besessen
Ok
Wie redet er ohne den mund zu öffnen ist er bauchredner oder
Landete auf der most wanted liste des fbi und schließlich im knast
Hallo florian
Peter perception fragt sich
Wie wird man reich
Das ist ganz einfach
In dem man mehr geld behält als ausgibt
Ich bin schon sehr früh ehrgeizig gewesen als junior national spieler im basketball kam ich an die harvard universität
Dann hatte ich an der harvard business school feinschliff bekommen das ist noch mal so
Die härteste finanz universität die man sich vorstellen kann
Der wird ein beigebracht wie sie richtig zu beißen dann wurde ich finanzunternehmer nachdem ich mit den besten investoren weltweit
Einige jahre zusammengearbeitet hat ich würde jetzt ja ich würde jetzt ja sagen
Er findet sich geil aber die sache ist die wahrscheinlich hat er auch sogar grund sich geil zu fühlen
Ganz unternehmer baute ich zweimal in fünf jahren milliardenunternehmen auf und die pyramide dieser branche das sind die hedge form manager
Das sind vielleicht weltweit 50 die selber milliardäre sind und unsummen bewegen einen unvorstellbaren einfluss haben easy money easy life
Da sehe ich dazu affengriff fragt sich was macht ein hedge form manager das frage ich mich auch hedge form manager werden
Außerordentlich gut bezahlt geile antwort was macht eigentlich ein hedge form manager hedge form manager werden außere werden gut bezahlt
Das ist die top antworter okay da kommt aber noch mehr kommt bestimmt noch mehr von manager werden
Außerordentlich gut bezahlt der anspruch ist in allen marktphasen geld zu verdienen der markt fällt
Kohle für die kunden der markt steigt kohle für die kunden der markt macht gar kohle für die kunden kohle für die kunden
Wenn du das affen geil machst ja kleiner hinweis dann wirst du außerordentlich gut bezahlt okay
Ja das leben das wird schon mal nichts für mich aber es ist fast schon verrückt arbeitstage von 16 stunden 100 stunden wochen sind standard
Das ist aber auch was ich denke dass der auch echt überzeugt von der sache ist
Und wenn man von der sache überzeugt ist lässt sich dort einfacher 16 stunden die woche arbeiten
Der typ tropft gerade so vor sympathie ich glaube in dieser in dieser position musst du nicht sympathisch sein
Keiner will zweitbester werden wir nehmen direkten einfluss wo wir können auf die unternehmensgestaltung weil wir die maximale rendite haben wollen
Und wenn wir auf angriff gehen damals zumindest dann ging das auch in die andere richtung haben wir uns dafür eingesetzt dass die werte purzeln
Weil bei fallenden kursen zu verdienen und bei steigenden kursen das war die mantra meines da seins
Mehmet beider fragt sich wie viel hast du damals verdient viel hört sich vielleicht degeneriert an aber
Geiler intro satze halbjahr teilweise 20 millionen 30 millionen das vermögen entstand durch fantastische renditen mit höchste mit einer sehr hohen gewinnbeteiligung also 20 prozent
Bei mir oder meiner organisation meine erste größere firma hatte damals ein börsenwert von grob eine milliarde demarkt nach fünf jahren die andere
Auch nach fünf jahren halt eine milliarde euro die letzte war in der london stock exchange einer der 250 größten unter der milliarde geht da nichts
Und die andere davor auch einer der größten finanzdienstleister der unabhängigen hast du es nur wegen des geldes getan auf keinen fall
Wer meint dass milliardär sein oder steinreich und berühmt job ist der macht einen riesen denkfehler mir ging es eigentlich nur darum auch heute noch das was ich angehe mit absoluter spitzenleistung zu machen
Ob das heute da musste ja da musste wahrscheinlich echt die richtige person für sein beziehungsweise die richtige die richtige einstellung für haben also für mich wäre das definitiv schon mal gar nichts weil ich bin faul wie sau
Ich habe oft erzählt aber man hätte spinnt wieder was ist denn da los heute komplett für ein arsch und ob das als influencer gilt als börsenbrief ja sogar karitativ ich möchte nicht zweitbester sein
Kommandos muss der progamer noch werden easy möchte von dir wissen was hast du von dem geld gekauft viel spielzeuge die man kaum nutzte also irgendwann mal zwei private flugzeuge eine nette kleine superjacht
Ach ja so eine kleine so eine kleine superjacht also verteilt auf vier fünf größe immobilien der hat die bechigs gemacht apartments in london new york kunstsammlung privat so einiges war sinnvoll vieles war einfach nur
schwachsinnig und das ironischste war auf meiner jacht habe ich glaube ich sechs tage verbracht und in einem mein palazzo in mabea der ehemals der saudi arabischen familie gehörte mit 2300 quadratmeter eine schlappe nacht
hat sich ja gelohnt möchte von dir wissen wie viele stunden am tag hast du gearbeitet sechs mal 16 stunden plus sechs stunden am sonntag das kannst du das kannst du nur machen wenn du voll hinter der sache stehst ja auch wenn du
dein schwimmbad vor der tür hast den tennisplatz ist vor der tür den helikopterplatz ist vor der tür dein privat so ist vor der tür du hast putzfrau das kocht das chauffeur das kapitän du hast piloten und so weiter und du machst sonst gar nichts aber die schlafzeit war auch nur vier stunden maximal vier also
fünf stunden schlafen war der reinste luxus waren auch manchmal drei waren auch manchmal drei tage ohne pennen also ein extremes energie level holbusters 420 möchte von dir wissen hast du damals viel geguckt wenn du deine physik vernachlässigt und dein
ragel ihren verniebels wirst du sehr schnell krasse fehlentscheidungen machen also in diesen themen in diesen phasen als hedgefonds manager no fucking way ab und zu mal vielleicht ein joint geraucht wurde mir auch vorgeworfen aber mehr war überhaupt nicht drin
besser möchte von dir wissen haben frauen mit dir geschlafen nur wegen des geldes ich hatte lange zeiten also viele jahre meines lebens privat direktive die gegen mich gearbeitet haben als bestens dokumentiert und dann wird man
äußerst vorsichtig bei frauen die einen super gut finden das kann ich mir vorstellen ich nicht der erste ich bin nicht der beste ich bin nicht der schönste und ich bin auch nicht der längste und das dieser mythos den kann man können die frauen so schön bespielen und da werde ich sehr allergisch und sehr vorsichtig kann man wie bekommen
er betont sehr aber gerne sehr das kann ich aber echt vorstellen dass sie da ein bisschen skeptisch bist also ich meine der hat ja wahrscheinlich das gefühl dass im laufend einer an kragen will man kann die illusion der liebe kaufen und die wahre liebe kannst du nicht kaufen einer seelenverwandtschaft das kann ich kaufen dafür braucht ich eigentlich fast vier erzählt um das zu
verstehen lolljesus möchte von dir wissen lolljesus einen über eine zeit von ob sein bodyguard auch exenmensch war 20 jahren circa hatte ich verschiedene teams von bodyguards in deutschland wir auch im kanzleramt tätig waren in südafrika abgehärtete so mal freedom fighter entweder gegen die südafrikaner
oder im bürgerkrieg in zimbabwe teils mossart leute mi5 und so weiter ja klar jetzt will das wissen viele nicht viele eine ganze menge zwei hände voll wirkliche feinde ich hatte auch meinen bodyguard dabei in karakas 2006 ende 2006 da wurde ich opfer eines attentats die kugel steckt noch mal im zwölften rücken wir
btf der dienstleister den ich in karakas beansprucht hatte der hatte halt nicht eine sauber gepanzerte limousine die konnte man mit einer schwerkalibriken pistole könnte man die durchballern also pum pum pum pum pum da war das fenster am arsch und ich auch und ich habe
die kugel hier kassiert todeslocke und ihr wissen wie fühlt es sich an das sagt angeschossen zu werden also in meinem fall sich weh getan ich habe ja meine linke lunge größtenteils verloren meine melz komplett es strömte so viel blut raus
dass meine hose und das obere also mein hemd war auch komplett rot es war sogar blut in meinen schuhen easykiller sagt warum schießen menschen auf solche banker ich vermute mal nicht dass irgendwelche random leute auf solche banker oder auf
ihn schießen sondern irgendjemand dem er massig geld gekostet hat also was auch immer da gelaufen ist keine ahnung aber ich gehe mal davon aus wenn einer was gegen ihn hat dann ist das jemand der auch durchaus über finanzielle mittel verfügt sich so einen anschlag
leisten zu können dann überleben weil das krankenhaus was ich behandelt hatte die hatten so ein zentrifugal gerät also das blut was bei mir rausfloss das wurde wieder verarbeitet kam wieder in meinen kreislauf zurück aber das verblüffende an dem so was da war dass mein bodyguard
ein schuss ins kniebe kam der fahrer wurde gänzlich ignoriert der wurde später noch mal ein bisschen ernsthaft in einem klären gespräch von meiner truppe verhör was da los war wie darf man sich dieses verhör vorstellt die brust
und ich kriegst ich hätte in die brust bekommen und in den kopf wenn ich den typen nicht einen halben arm abgebissen hätte ich bin dafür gott dankbar dass ich hier stehen darf
wie was animations möchte von dir wissen macht geld glücklich geld macht nicht glücklich aber gold schlösser und privat scherz nein du musst höllig aufpassen in der liga in der ich dann gespielt habe bist du eigentlich in einem gold bespickten hamsterrad
deine zeitliche verfügbarkeit ist relativ gering du bist zwar meinst du bist selbstbestimmt aber dein vermögen fängt an dich zu bestimmen ganz andere dimension okay denkt mal drüber nach kill all camper möchte von dir wissen was war dein größter deal
publizitätsträchtig war am allermeisten die sanierung von bruxiard dortmund acht der ist das waren die so krass überschuldet und das habe ich doch schon wirklich ach der ist das ich hatte keine ahnung wer das ist
effizit her dass die gesamte finanz und sportpresse sagte er haben hatten hirnsturz dass er diesen maroden laden überhaupt noch angeht und versucht zu retten der wert des unternehmens ist vom tiefpunkt von ungefähr 60 millionen dann auf knapp eine milliarde euro
milliarde ist so ist bei ihm glaube ich so die strelle wo er sagt okay jetzt ist gut das muss unter einer milliarde macht man es nicht ja es war ein riesen erfolge auch wenn man das mir nicht irgendwie anrechnet heute in dortmund ich muss da drüber stehen
6 monat dankeschön excellent subscription chat IQ steigt heute mit uns unermessliche wissen wie taucht man unter schluss ist schluss das kapitel finanz milliardär maker und mover meister des universums war für mich durch null bock mehr ich war unglücklich
und bin dann in meinen privatflieger gegangen handy wegschmeißen richtig viel geld dabei und dann ging es halt los dann ging die reise los ja und genau welchen weg und wohin und soweit das hat keinen zu interessieren
olafu west möchte von dir wissen wo warst du auf deiner flucht überall mindestens 50 länder sehr viel zeit meister des universums ja wahrscheinlich hatte auch allen ich meine ich weiß es nicht was er alles getrieben hat aber wahrscheinlich hat er auch kund genug sich geil zu finden sport sehr viel familie sehr viel kultur einfach ein innerster bedarf leben nachzuholen was in meinem ehrgeiz komplett
untergegangen ist brockings möchte von dir wissen wie hast du es geschafft dich so lange zu verstecken es gab eine kopfgeldjagd weil das vermögen das familienvermögen was damals noch bestand also eine gesunde neunstellige zahl das weckte auch eine gesunde neunstellige zahl da wurden 1,5 millionen auf meinen kopf ausgesetzt hatte eine sehr schöne jacht zu diesem zeitpunkt und die option war in die karibik zu fahren
oder in den pazifik richtung chile oder in norden haben wenn man so eine kleine jacht hat kann man das schon mal machen wenn das mein kapitän nicht weiß meine crew wie soll das denn dann bitte ein kopfgeldjäger wissen ich wusste ja selber nicht wo ich hinfahren will
hattest du gefälschte papiere sollte man in der presse nachlesen flames möchte von dir geschickt um schrift wie wurdest du gefasst anfang märz 2013 gab es dann einen haftbefehl gegen mich und der wurde über interpol an italiener transferiert ich war mit meiner exfrau zusammen
meinem sohn konrad und seiner warum haben sie ihn denn jetzt gesucht was hat er angestellt ich hab gesagt ich hab keine ich kenne den ich weiß was hat er denn gemacht wir waren in den uffizien das ist das ich mein hetschfront manager sein kann er ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht verboten
uns museum italiens auf immer standen sechs leute um mich und haben mich vor meine exfrau und meinem sohn und seiner freundin verhaftet und dann wie in einem jim's bond film geleiteten die mich nicht gesagt mit verdeckten handschellen
in den innenhof dieses wahnsinnigen museums und fuhren mich in einen ein eine villa bei der nirgendwo zu erkennen war dass es eine polizeitienststelle war es war eine heißt squadra mobile das ist die absolute elite einheit der italienischen polizei
dann begann ein echtes trauma regenbogen kotze interessiert er muss lachen er muss lachen über den namen jetzt haben sie jetzt weggeschnitten was hast du bei deiner festnahme gedacht
what the fuck was war das schlimmste im gefängnis die absolute hoffnungslosigkeit weil ich gefühlt hatte ich mit riesigen staatsvogel und organ wie amerika übermächtig und auch der schweiz zu tun
hoffnungslosigkeit leben zu ende multiple skillerose 260 da ging die staumsnehmer hoch ein beschissener ausblick keine möglichkeit sich zu bewegen das war das war das beschissens ein leben ist so wie du es kennst vorbei hast du einen selbstmord gedacht
ich habe das erweckt definitiv ich hatte auch zwei pillen mir organisiert dann kam diese überlegung hoch und dann hatte ich aber schon einen enormen glauben entwickelt habe gesagt es geht nicht
das leben wurde mir gegeben es wird irgendwann mal zu ende sein ich werde es mir nicht nehmen und ich werde auch nicht diese schwere last auf zukünftige generationen übertragen
mein daddy mein großvater mein urgroßvater hat verzweifelt und sich selber umgebracht moment was sein vater hat sich umgebracht sein opa und sein opa haben sie umgebracht moment das habe ich jetzt bestimmt falsch verstanden
was ist da los ach er redet aus sicht der enkel die enkel über ihn ach ok das hat mich jetzt echt verwirrt gerade das will er seinen enkel nicht antun ja ja jetzt habe ich es auch kapiert jetzt habe ich es auch kapiert
jetzt habe ich es auch kapiert zwei pillen war in der toilette es war es chicken beast fragt sich wie viel von dem geld ist noch übrig ein recht hoher zweistelliger millionenbetrag ich würde sagen gesunde summe
weil es arrestiert das ist öffentlich bekannt ob die zahl stimmt möchte ich nicht kommentieren der erzfeind fragt sich würdest du alles noch mal so machen ich glaube ich hätte einiges anders gemacht aber andererseits ganz klar bin ich dankbar dafür für dieses leben dass ich überhaupt noch lebe und jetzt ein zweites leben führen kann was doch extrem unterschiedlich ist zum ersten würdest du noch mal hetschbohr manager werden
ich glaube das war schon eine zeit weil ich diese ressourcen diese fehlkeiten jetzt im gemeinnütz im kreativen bereich auch einsetzen werde und das finde ich so super spannend diese fehlkeiten einfach anders eingesetzt und die hätte ich nicht wenn ich nicht in diesem hardcore geschäft als der absoluten spitze der pyramide nicht mich nicht zwei jahrzehnte bewegt hätte
ok ja das wäre kls wahrscheinlich auch gerne so was haben wir sonst auch schönes also wir haben jetzt noch vier vier videos zur auswahl oder fünf fünf videos zur auswahl die wir die wir gucken kann zwar wir können uns die javascript geschichte angucken ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt hinten drauf so das beste ist wir können uns noch eine doku über das jahr 2000 angucken von 90.000 bis 90.000
angucken von 1972 geht aber nur neun minuten wir können uns drüber auf wir können uns angucken wie sich hier kugelmagnet eddie über elektronik arts aufregt das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht schlecht oder wir gucken eine runde black ops 1
komm wir gucken erst mal was er was er über was er über bettel viel flamen mal gucken weiß gar nicht ob er ea flamt vielleicht sagt er auch ea beste tach wir reden noch mal über battlefields zukunft battlefields vergangenheit und battlefields aktuellen stand in so vielen kommentaren
battlefields aktuellen stand kann man nur eins dazu sagen das alles was man dazu sagen kann immer wiederholende argumente gelesen auf die ich jetzt einfach unbedingt mal eingehen möchte das sind kommentare wie ea will e nur geld verdienen
selbst natürlich will e geld verdienen schuld wer es noch kauft war doch klar dass ja schon ein bisschen was passiert als sie angekündigt haben das premium nicht mehr kommt premium hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun und mein persönlicher favorit war wieso habt ihr erwartet dass die entwickler drei jahre für lau arbeiten das ist das hatte ich auch das habe ich auch oft unter meinen videos wenn ich mich drüber beschwere dass irgendwas nicht richtig funktioniert oder dass man für die scheiße wieder geld bezahlen soll und sonst was das sagen ganz
viele leute ja max die entwickler die die die die sollen aber nicht umsonst arbeiten ich weiß gar nicht wie man die zusammenhang dazwischen dazwischen immer herstellt die entwickler sollen selbstverständlich ihr normales normales gehalt kriegen und ein tragfähiges business model entwickeln ist ja ist ja aufgabe der nicht meine aufgabe sondern die des herstellers irgendwo und der muss dann letztendlich auch die programmierer bezahlen aber wenn im vorfeld was anderes angekündigt wird als dann
kommt dann hat es ja nichts damit zu tun dass man die entwickler nicht bezahlen will sondern man hat die leute schlicht und ergreifend verarscht ja egal egal gucken wir weiter also zum letzten möchte ich unbedingt mal was sagen und zwar natürlich sollen die entwickler nicht für lau arbeiten ja kein menschen erwartet dass die gratis arbeiten und das hat auch keiner gedacht also an alle die das geschrieben haben ganz ehrlich googelt doch mal was ein service game ist und dann guckt mal was für
geld man mit einem service game verdienen kann naja es sei denn es ist anthem
dann wisst ihr auch warum es sei denn es ist anthem
punkt eins natürlich wollen die nur geld verdienen das ist der publisher jeder publisher will immer nur alle wollen sie geld verdienen meint ihr der entwickler will kein geld verdienen alle wollen sie geld verdienen
natürlich wollen die das nicht machen um dir einen gefallen zu tun deswegen muss das produkt aber trotzdem gut sein ansonsten haben alle wollen sie geld verdienen überlegt euch doch mal leute ich finde auch prinzipiell jetzt nichts verwerfliches dran ist es die frage ob man da jetzt wirklich über sind bildlich über leichen geht aber mal angenommen wenn sich dann auch immer darüber darüber aufgeregt wird teilweise dass irgendwelche manager zu viel geld verdienen und sonst was mal angenommen euer chef kommt zu euch und sagt hier ihr kriegt mehr geld da würde doch auch keiner sagen
also ich finde für das was ich mache kriege ich schon genug warum warum warum es würde keiner machen genauso wenn sich darüber aufgeregt wird dass irgendwelche management leute so viel verdienen die wahren leute über die man sich aufregen muss ist wer den für das gehalt eingestellt hat dass der das gehalt nimmt was er ausgehandelt hat in seinem vertrag steht finde ich überhaupt nichts verwerfliches dagegen
wer den eingestellt hat da muss man sich mal fragen ob man den noch alle tassen im strang sind ich ein verfechter des service modells über dem premium ich auch ich auch muss an der stelle auch mal mich auch ich habe ich lasse jetzt erst mal ich lasse ihn jetzt erst mal erzählen eine firma bringt ein produkt raus und bekommt dann das geld eine firma verbessert das produkt patch das produkt bringt maps oder content raus und bekommt danach
das geld dieses geld muss nicht zwingend in form eines dlc sein den mann kauft das ein fertiges produkt ist das kann auch einfach ein live service sein das heißt man kann auch einfach ein game spielen es kommt ein geiler patch und dann sagt man ey das war ein geiler patch da waren geile maps bei jetzt habe ich lust die entwickler weiter zu supporten und mann kauft etwas im shop es macht leute geben die immer noch nicht verstehen dass dieses modell aufgeht aber es ist im prinzip genauso wie überall klar guckt euch pass and back sein da funktioniert das seit 2012 nicht für die brötchen bevor es
sie überhaupt in den backofen geschoben hat also der weggang vom premium modell auf ein service modell ist eigentlich der absolut richtige und gute schritt gewesen ist das battlefield eins ist das battlefield eins
künftiges bezahl modell überhaupt es zu haben denn sorry aber map dlc ist einfach von vor vorgestern alle erfolgreichen studios machen es momentan die spieler belohnen die entwickler nachdem das game weiterhin schockt wer dauerhaft ein spiel spielt und immer weiter spaß hat und immer neue patches updates und content bekommt der wird auch sein geld da rein stecken zumindest die leute die eh willens sind einen dlc finde ich auch okay wenn der hersteller die sache ordentlich handelt ist okay blizzard bei offer watch hat
halt verkackt ja über über die ich hätte ich hätte die auch weiter supportet wenn das spiel mir noch spaß gemacht hätte stecken meist mehr in das game am ende rein als sie mit einem einfachen dlc reingesteckt hätten das ist und tribulon sagt skins kaufe ich mir nicht das ist auch gar nicht erforderlich bei dem modell es reicht wenn sich andere leute skins kaufen du jetzt persönlich muss was ja gar nicht machen für die firma natürlich muss content nicht immer bezahlt kommen der kann auch aus der community kommen stichwort mods und so weiter
das sprengt aber jetzt den rahmen wenn wir von einem aktuellen spielmodell ausgehen so wie es in der wirtschaft gehandhabt wird so wie man ein spiel von einem entwickler kauft dann sollte es so laufen das produkt muss rauskommen und für den kaufpreis muss es erstmal schon mal funktionieren und gut
gebe ich auch das hatte ich in dem anderen video schon gesagt genau das hat betty vielfalt falsch gemacht das spiel kam schon nicht fertig raus jetzt hast du also 60 euro für ein spiel ausgegeben was fallout 76 hätten wir da auch noch so als beispiel nicht richtig funktioniert aber das
potential an sich ist da du merkst ok das könnte echt ein gutes spiel werden aber ein zwei patches die müssten noch sein und ich will jetzt gar nicht auf das thema eingehen zum thema mit frauen im weltkrieg und so weiter ich weiß viele leute haben ist deswegen nicht gekauft und ganz ehrlich wenn computer spiel nicht von der realität unterscheiden kann bitte das muss jeder selber das deswegen das war nicht das problem dass das war nicht das problem die die vermarktung dabei war das problem dass da frauen im spiel sind juckt doch kein mensch aber wenn du wenn
du auf wir sind das authentische game aller zeiten macht und dann und es war es geht ja überhaupt nicht um die frauen und dann sachen macht die halt nicht authentisch sind oder quasi sachen entgegen dem sogar wie es in echt passiert ist macht dann regt man sich darüber auf nicht dass frauen im game sind das einzige was mich persönlich habe ich ja schon mal gesagt an den frauen in battlefield nervt ist nicht dass es frauen sind sondern dass die einen viel nervigeren rumschreit
haben als die männlichen soldaten das ist das was mich nervt und ich mag allgemein leute die schreien ich und frauen die hochfrequent schreien ist da habe ich echt das ist aber so ich krieg da irgendwie probleme wenn ich zu viel frauen schreien aber das ist so mein persönliches problem ja und deswegen das ist das was mich bei den frauen im battlefield genervt hat dass da frauen im spiel sie nervt mich überhaupt nicht in warzone spiele ich sogar eine frau weil das model
kleiner ist aber die leute haten jeden der das spiel trotzdem gekauft hat und ich kann nur sagen meine fresse es gibt halt einfach leute für die ist es in einem computerspiel nicht relevant ich bin absolut kein fan von
irgendeiner art von radikalismus in irgendeiner art und weise egal ob das irgendwelche hardcore feministin sind oder frauenhasser männerhass es scheiß egal für mich sind das alles bescheuerte einstellungen die nichts in der realität zu suchen haben aber letzten ende in der realität sind sie halt da leider aber ich gebe mir da prinzipiell voll recht ob das produkt jetzt taugt oder nicht das heißt für die 60 euro die man ausgegeben hat war es meiner meinung nach erstmal ein guter und solider kauf wenn natürlich dann aber die patches nicht kommt dann kann ich nicht erwarten dass die leute im shop sofort wieder noch mehr
mit reinstecken wer gibt es mehr geld aus wenn das kernprodukt schon nicht richtig korrekt wurde wenn das für den kaufpreis schon nicht die volle leistung bietet die man eigentlich haben möchte jetzt kann man eins von zwei dingen machen man kann entweder sagen meine kunden sind nicht zufrieden mit dem produkt ich habe ja aber einen shop oder man macht die taktik und beleidigt seine kunden jetzt das spielgut patch das vernünftig und legt ein bisschen geld aus um wirklich mal content rauszuhauen und das bekomme ich dann von zufriedenen glücklichen
kunden zurück oder man macht es wie ei man denkt sich jetzt müssen wir erstmal den shop machen jetzt müssen wir warten bis aus dem shop das geld kommt weil sonst weiß ich ja gar nicht ob es sich lohnt weiterhin noch in das spiel zu investieren
das ist halt stomps logik bvl bvl ja klar wobei man muss sagen die machen da mit sicherheit irgendwelche analysen einfach nur da sitzen und gucken ob das shop läuft machen die bestimmt nicht und ja ohne warzone gäbe ich dir recht niklas ohne warzone wäre modern warfare tot
der multiplayer finde ich ist mit der schlechteste multiplayer in einem call of duty den wir die letzten jahren hatten und ich habe schon nicht viele gespielt
das ist dieses typische bvl schwachsinn denken was einfach in der realität nicht richtig funktioniert ein kunde kauft gerne und gibt auch gerne mehr aus wenn er dafür auch eine gegenleistung bekommt bleibt die gegenleistung aus kannst du nicht erwarten dass er reinkascht ea ist was das angeht aber verwöhnt denn die leute haben immer schon vorbestellt wieso guckt euch asia mmos an da wird auch reingekascht ohne ende und ohne content
immer schon prämium gekauft bevor auch nur klar wurde was überhaupt da richtig drin ist man wusste nur so und so viele maps kommen und die gut sind was das für ein setting ist keine ahnung katze im sack kaufen das ist gewohnt da sind die verwöhnt die zeiten sind aber vorbei und das muss auch jetzt mal lernen deswegen finde ich den satz immer so witzig wenn leute schreiben ich will nur geld verdienen selber schuld bla nie hat eben ja kein geld verdient denn das was auch viele geschrieben haben kauft den scheiß nicht sprecht mit eurem portemonnaie ist exakt das was passiert ist die leute haben kein weiteres content
haben kein weiteres genau ausgegeben genau und wenn man wenn man so bescheuert ist wie ea und die leuten sagt kauft das game nicht dann ja muss man sich auch nicht wundern den zusatz content und die patches die eben gefehlt haben und damit hat ea auch eine bittere lektion gelernt nämlich alle anderen verdienen uns um mit diesem modell fortnight league of legends sucht euch irgendwas aus selbst rainbow six könnte man da noch mit rein nehmen obwohl die natürlichen season pass drin haben das funktioniert da aber natürlich ein bisschen anders wegen der operator alter chat was das wieder für
die diskussion wenn man wenn man in game wenn man in dem spiel männer models und frauen models hat und das ein spiel ist was multiplayer ist also sprich spieler spieler gegen spieler ist dann ist es überhaupt kein problem das es männer und frauen im spiel gibt wo es balance technischen problem ist wenn frauen kleinere models haben und schwerer zu hinten sind als männer das wird dann nämlich resultieren dass die leute die interessiert sind in dem spiel und gewinnen wollen einfach immer frauen spielen weil sie als schwerer zu treffen sind
und nicht mehr das was sie wirklich spielen wollen und das einfachste die sache zu beheben ist einfach männer und frauen models gleich groß machen fertig es spricht doch überhaupt nichts dagegen dass man männer und frauen in spiel rein macht und einfach die models gleich groß macht gut ist die können ja die hitboxen die hitboxen gleich groß macht wenigstens ja dass du jetzt schlecht irgendwie den den zwei meter zehn muskel protz und irgendwie eine kleine zierliche
165 frauen modell dass die in game auch wirklich exakt die gleichen abmaße haben okay das kann ich verstehen aber zumindest die hitbox sollte ähnlich sein alternativ macht man dann halt nicht riesen typen und mini frauen in das game als als model variation von einem zum anderen extrem sondern man guckt halt dass man so ungefähr ähnlich große sachen macht ich meine du musst nicht in zwei meter zehn typen du musst nicht die 160 frauen im kind nimmt einfach was ich alle um paar 70 groß so
oder um 1 80 groß oder sowas so gut ist hauptsache die hitboxen sind gleich gut gleich groß das ist ja das wichtige an der sache dass das gameplay technisch keinen unterschied macht unterm strich dann ist dann ist doch alles ok im kern ist es auch ein service game alle verdienen fette kohle und
ea ist einfach zu tun ja außer bei ente zu blöd weil die einfach nicht raffen ich muss erste leistung bringen bevor ich das geld verlangen kann und wenn ich ein service game doch er rafft das doch doch ich glaube schon das ea das rafft aber
ei ist nicht mehr oder vor allem da ist in kombination mit ei ist nicht mehr in der lage abzuliefern die kriegen es einfach nicht mehr hin das ist denen schon klar aber die kriegen es einfach nicht gebacken
das scheint an vielen vorbeigegangen zu sein es wurde als service game als langfristiges supportetes game angekündigt dann darf man sich nicht wundern wenn die leute sagen
dann kaufe ich vielleicht auch was jeder der im shop da schon vorher geld ausgegeben hat dem kann man sagen du ganz ehrlich selber schuld was gibst du das auch aus aber das war ja gerade der große vorteil daran als angekündigt wurde das ea tatsächlich auch zum service modell geht wenn ea geld verdienen will dann ist genau dieses modell was sie sich ausgesucht haben eigentlich ein garant dafür dass content und qualität kommen muss denn man müsste ja eigentlich davon ausgehen dass alles daran setzen wird fetten umsatz
zu machen und der blieb jetzt halt einfach komplett aus und das hat sich absolut selbst zu verschulden das finde ich persönlich gesagt nicht am kunden wir reden hier nicht von fifa oder so wir reden hier von battlefield eine spiele serie die bisher auch wenn das nicht jedermanns immer geschmack trifft aber bisher immer vernünftige spiele rausgebracht hat manchmal halt auch erst mit patches manchmal auch sofort zum release manche spiele gefallen dem einen nicht wegen dem setting battlefield war schon immer so dass es wenig leute gibt die wirklich jedes battlefield feiern es gab immer leute die irgendwelche
aussetzer gemacht haben das finde ich jetzt kacke blau aber im kern waren es immer vernünftige spiele und waren immer den kaufwert so jetzt geht man davon aus man hat eine spiele serie die gut ist die jetzt sich selber verpflichtet gute qualität zu bringen weil sonst kein geld reinkommt und das ging in die hose natürlich ja die kriegen das die kriegen auch nichts gescheites mehr game mäßig abgeliefert über schuld ihr habt halt guckt euch die letzten bettel vieles an was ich ich muss mir noch mal unterbrechen was ich halt auch immer total lustig finde dass die so sehr drauf rumreißen
so nach dem motto wir hören auf unsere community unsere community ist die besten und danke dass wir so eine schöne community haben und wir machen alles was die leute im endeffekt was dann da rauskommt ist total an dem vorbei was die leute wollen sich drauf ein service modell zu entwickeln was funktioniert aber wenn ich dann kommentare lese wie die kunden sind selber schuld sorry aber für mich war das der grund battlefield 5 auch zu kaufen weil es ein guter schritt von ea war zu sagen pass auf wir machen das mit einem service weil sonst verdienen wir gar kein geld die haben
jetzt da zwei jahre das game versucht halt zu fixen aber sie haben nicht genug reingesteckt sie haben nicht genug investiert hyper boy wer wirklich viel verkauft und jedes jahr diesen fifa karten crime macht und dafür geld ausgibt dem ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen das kann ich das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen wie man das macht ein anzugträger am schreibtisch da gesessen hat und gesagt hat ja aber wenn das dann nicht reinkommt dann lohnt sich das nicht und bei fifa ging es auch besser und dann hatten wir ja premium da hatten wir gleich das geld da wussten wir wie viel wir haushalten
können die checken einfach die aktuelle zeit nicht die checken einfach nicht dass die leute richtig fett knete rein buddern wenn sie spaß am spiel haben und das ist genau der unterschied zwischen ea und vielen anderen studios oder publishers ist dass
ea einfach nicht checkt dass die leute einfach nur ein gutes spiel die checken das doch doch doch die checken das die kriegen das aber nicht hin ich will dass das da gibt es nichts was man kann ja man kann ja bvl leuten jetzt viel vorwerfen aber so einfach zusammenhängen werden die schon checken aber die kriegen es nicht mal gebacken und dazu kommt wenn vielleicht da ist was gescheites basteln oder oder ich kann es ja nicht sagen nur da ist kriegst nicht mehr
gebacken selbst wenn die was gescheites basteln dass das durch einflussnahme von außen so umgestrickt wird halt in in bahnen dass es nicht mehr funktioniert die kriegen es einfach nicht nicht gebacken den ist das mit sicherheit klar dass sie mit gut mit dass sie mit einem guten spiel auch mit diesem spiel mehr verdienen können das ist ja der zusammenhang der ist so klar wie wie mein wie mein leak in der picking suppe im endeffekt aber die kriegen es nicht mal gebacken
zeit investieren können und dann sind die auch bereit geld auszugeben das ist eigentlich jetzt auch nichts weltbewegend verrücktes oder wo man denkt so vor mein blown das ist eigentlich total normal ich weiß nicht warum ihr das nicht rafft aber wenn mir leute erzählen dass sie das wussten dass das in die
hose geht dann nur weil sie pauschalen hasst sowieso haben und egal was sie machen selbst wenn die free to play game rausbringen würden würden die leute noch meckern und sagen jetzt bringt es gratis raus und weißen sie das ist sind halt leute die kann es mit logik ähnlich kommen aber denkt mal kurz drüber nach hat sich mit dem service modell eigentlich verpflichtet vernünftig zu arbeiten oder halt wirklich kein geld damit zu verdienen nur mit dem kauf des spiels haben die die kosten für so ein projekt mit zwei hätten diesen firestorm shit einfach mal weglassen sollen
firestorm war auch so ein ding wo ich mir denke das ist nur entstanden nicht weil da ist gesagt hat ja nicht weil die designer bei da ist gesagt aber ja für den battlefield wäre so ein firestorm royal modus battle royale modus was gut ist firestorm ist wahrscheinlich nur entstanden weil er gesagt hat lasst mal einen firestorm ein lasst mal einen battle royale modus einbauen
was mit sicherheit auch sehr viel entwicklungszeit und und ressourcen gekostet hat da steckt keine liebe drin sagt rison ja das finde ich merkt man bei vielen aktuellen spielen dass so das gewisse herzblut der entwickler auch fehlt oder das würde ich noch nicht mal sagen dass viele viele entwickler halt an projekten heute arbeiten die sie halt machen müssen weil sie es letztendlich ihr job ist aber dass das keine projekte
sind wo sie sagen ja das ist das spiel was schon immer machen wollte locker nicht raus locker nicht das war kein gutes geschäft für ea und deswegen es ist genau richtig gelaufen für für uns als kunden wir haben die message gesendet so eine scheiße machen wir nicht mit wir kaufen nicht die katze im sack bringen content dann zahlen wir auch gerne und wenn das leute von ea oder da ist sehen bringt vernünftigen content die leute werden dann auch ihr geld bei euch lassen aber ihr müsst euch erstmal wieder einen vernünftigen ruf erarbeiten wo die leute
sagen hey das spiel lohnt sich in anderen in anderen bereichen haben sie es ja auch geschafft wir müssen sowieso irgendwann noch mal über bettel von zwei reden weil ich da auch viele kommentare zu gelesen habe das
sprengt überhaupt nichts zu sagen epex legends da haben sie es ja auch einigermaßen gekriegt ist auch ein ea game warum kriegen sie es bei bettel fehlt nicht in vielleicht liegt es am ende ja auch gar nicht unbedingt bei ea vielleicht ist er wirklich bei da ist wobei auch das natürlich
eigentlich mittlerweile egal ist denn vielen ist auch nicht klar da ist ea und ea ist das müsste sich mal von ea lösen das geht nicht einzelne entwickler die leute die leute müssen mal gucken für was da ist steht
also da ist ea schon im namen drinnen das wird garantiert nicht passieren
aber das studio ist mittlerweile ea es gehört nicht nur ea es ist ea das ist eine firma mir ist halt einfach nur extrem wichtig dass die leute jetzt nicht denken dass es jetzt in die hose gegangen ist weil kein premium da war damit belohnt man ea nur so ein modell wieder einzuführen
ne ich muss sagen diese ganze service geschichte diese ganze service game geschichte ist das beste was einem passieren kann wenn das ein spiel ist was man gerne spielt und was man möglichst lange am leben haben möchte ähnlich im prinzip mmo abo modelle waren die vorreiter des service games in diesem sinn
ja und warum hatten mmos lange zeit ähm zumindest früher fast exklusiv ein abo modell weil die weil die subscriber nicht von einem monat auf dem anderen weg sind wenn du 600.000 subscriber hast du kannst ziemlich sicher davon ausgehen du hast nächsten monat immer noch ähnlich viele die leute werden nicht einfach sagen ok ich kündige meinen abos du hast nicht 600.000 subscriber und im nächsten monat 5 ja ähm das das war ja so der folger und wenn man wenn man ein spiel gerne spielt und möchte dass das möglichst lang am leben bleibt ist so eine service game geschichte eigentlich das beste was
ein passieren kann das problem ist nur wenn spiele explizit quasi dahin wie soll man sagen spiele fast schon vergewaltigt werden in die richtung service game guckt euch das neue go streaking an wo komische loot mechaniken eingeführt werden wo extra gegner hinzugefügt wurden in form von diesen komischen drohnen dass man die lootwaffen überhaupt braucht weil im rest war es total sinnlos wenn man sich so ein zusammengestöckeltes game wie anthem anguckt das ist das eigentliche problem nicht die nicht das service game gedanke an sich
den gibt es ja schon lange genau das was ea in als denkfehler wieso muss alles größer schöner sein weil jedes spiel vor allem multiplayer spiele permanente pflege brauchen sei es anti cheat geschichten sei es balance updates sei es neue maps neue klassen neue skills balancing geschichten multiplayer spiele und gerade multiplayer spiele brauchen permanenten support dass die eine weile aktuell sind oder dass die eben eine weile gespielt werden und das auch eine weile spaß macht
war eigentlich war eigentlich schon immer so welche multiplayer spiele sind jahrelang aktuell geblieben ohne support das einzige was mir einfällt das einzige was mir einfällt wo es aber anderweitig war war starcraft eins starcraft eins hatte jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel support von von blizzard blizzard seite aber die hatten die koreaner und die hatten halt viele viele
drum herum patches war glaube ich war starcraft nicht so viel aber das war ein wirklich auch ein absoluter glücksgriff glücksgriff bei blizzard dass das dass das so so gut funktioniert team fortress ja stimmt tatsächlich team fortress wird immer noch relativ viel gespielt obwohl blizzard obwohl obwohl welf gesagt hat gehen uns am arsch vorbei aber es ist so oft ausnahmen bestätigen die regel aber mmos ohne updates werden nicht gespielt multiplayer spiele ohne updates werden nicht gespielt allein schon im
bezug auf die ganze anti cheat thematik du kannst ein spiel war gerade multiplayer spiel nicht nicht nicht aktuell halten ohne ohne auch halbwegs funktionieren ein anti cheat und auch leute die sich um reports kümmern und leute die sich um statistik auswertung kümmern wer da irgendwie bescheißt dann endet das dann irgendwann wie in wie gibt es across fire wo quasi jede lobby nur aus cheatern besteht und gewinnt wer der beste den besten cheat hat dass es nur geht wenn man erst das
geld von den leuten nimmt das wollen wir nicht zurück ich weiß es gibt leute die wollen das zurück aber glaubt mir ihr wollt es in wirklichkeit eigentlich nicht zurück ea kann auch einfach mal lernen qualität abzuliefern und dann das geld zu bekommen andere film können es wie gesagt auch und das ist halt einfach so ja ea will team fortress 2 gibt es wahrscheinlich neue hüte ab und zu noch aber wenn sie mein geld wollen dann müssen sie sich auch ins zeug legen sonst bekommen sie es nicht und so solltet ihr es auch handhaben und ja den kaufpreis für ein ea titel der mir taugt wo ich beim zock
nee meine forschung eine vorschau ist abgekackt ich hab gesagt das stream ist aber dass die miss nicht
den kaufpreis ist mal wer den werde ich auch weiterhin ausgeben dann lasse ich mir auch von keinem ein quatschen wenn mir jetzt schon leute sagen das nächste bälle fiert muss man boykottieren können wir auch gerne mal nächt im video drüber sprechen aber ich persönlich sag mir einfach ich warte doch erst mal ab im kummer das produkt an
Ich sag so viel, wie ich bereit bin für das, was ich im Gegenzug bekomme, dann halt auch auszugeben.
Und bei Battlefield 5 war es so, ich hab jetzt den Kauf des Spiels einfach nicht bereut.
Tut mir leid, wenn ihr zu den Leuten gehört, die das Spiel von Anfang an schon gehasst haben, ist das völlig okay.
Ich hab das Spiel...
Aber ihr müsst akzeptieren, dass es auch Leute gibt...
Leute, ich versteh...
Es gibt doch nicht nur, man hasst das Spiel oder man vergöttert das Game.
Die Wahrheit liegt doch meistens irgendwo dazwischen.
Also, ich denke, es gibt wenige, die gesagt haben, von Anfang an, oh, Battlefield 1, so ein Scheiß.
Und es gibt wenige, die gesagt haben, von Anfang an, Battlefield 5, das beste Spiel überhaupt.
Bei mir war es so, ich hab mir das Spiel gekauft, hab gesagt, eigentlich ist es ganz okay, aber der Funke springt nicht so richtig über.
Fertig.
Weder großer Hate, noch großer Hype.
Ich hab einfach gesagt, ah, irgendwie ist es nicht so meins.
So, gut ist es.
Das werden die meisten gemacht haben.
Und das, und das sind auch gerade die Problemfälle für EA oder für DICE.
Weil richtige Hater bleiben bei dem Spiel, genauso wie richtige Fans.
Deswegen sind ja die größten Hater meistens auch die größten Fans.
Spiel gespielt haben in Alpha und Beta und gesagt haben, ey, das macht mir Spaß, das ist für mich ein geiles Spiel, ich hab da Bock drauf.
Das müsst ihr akzeptieren, das müsst ihr ja nicht gut finden.
Aber ihr könnt doch nicht mit jedem auf Finger zeigen, hoho, selber Schuld, ihr habt das Spiel gekauft.
Das Spiel war okay.
Es war nur der Live-Support, der scheiße war.
Und das ist einzig und allein die EAs Schuld.
Und die sind auch diejenigen, die am meisten jetzt darunter leiden.
Weil ich hab meine hunderte Spielstunden aus dem Spiel raus für die 60 Euro.
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht beklagen.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt aber trotzdem nicht weiterzocken, wenn der Support eingestellt wird und das Spiel einfach nie komplett fertig gemacht wird.
Das ist einfach ein Unterschied.
Lernt euch mal ein bisschen differenzieren.
Man muss nicht immer alles nur schwarz und weiß sehen.
Das ist exakt das, was ich gerade gesagt hab.
Man muss einfach mal ein bisschen in der Mitte und nach links und rechts gucken können.
Und es ist einfach nur mein Feedback, es ist einfach nur meine Meinung.
Es ist auch nichts Schlimmes dabei.
Ich hab den Eindruck irgendwie, er wirkt ein wenig aufgebracht bei dieser Thematik.
Nicht traurig, ich weine auch nicht rum.
Es ist einfach nur ein Feedback.
Lasst uns einfach als Community einfach mal über solche Sachen sprechen.
Und da möchte ich jetzt gerne einfach mal eure Meinung dazu hören.
Also, hauts mir in die Kommentare.
Es wäre natürlich nice, wenn ihr noch einen Daumen rauf oder runter gebt.
Natürlich auch, wenn ihr es kann gefallen, dann ruhig einen Daumen nach unten.
Dann weiß ich wenigstens, wo man ist.
Ach stimmt, wir sind noch nicht eingeloggt.
Und ja, also wie gesagt, einfach mal den Abo-Button drücken, wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie merkt.
Mensch, geiler Typ.
Tschüss.
Moin, guys.
Ähm.
Was hat gerade ein riesen Comment gerade im Chat gepostet?
Ich war kurz hier rüber, ob es das...
Oh hier, ja da Basti, BastiW hat einen Comment.
Hast du schon von The Culling gehört?
Ja, gehört schon, aber nie gespielt und mir auch nix von angeguckt.
War zu Anfangszeiten von PUBG auch ein Battle Royale Titel.
Erst als Early Access Titel, lief nicht.
Und war nach einem Monat weg vom Fenster.
Ein Jahr später als Vollpreistitel ohne wirklich Neues mit alten Bugs.
Und auch nicht wirklich der Renner.
Und nun versuchen sie es ein erneutes.
Das habe ich gelesen letztens, ja.
Mir hat das Spiel nicht viel gesagt.
Abomodell.
Aber jetzt kommts.
5 Euro für das...
Oh das geht doch.
Äh, was?
5 Euro für das Game mit einem Token pro Tag.
Hä?
Ein Token gleich ein Game?
Ah, es ist im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Pay to Play.
Äh.
Wie will man das denn bei einem Spiel, was eh keinen interessiert, durchsetzen?
Die wollen wahrscheinlich den letzten Cent aus den verbliebenen Fans noch rausbekommen und gut ist.
Gut funktionieren kann das nicht.
Was die sich dabei gedacht haben, weiß keiner, sagt der Rison.
Also, pff, das habe ich so auch noch nicht gesehen.
Okay, komm wir gucken noch eine Runde Black Ops 2, äh Black Ops 1.
What's going on?
Der hört sich heute voll glücklich an.
Was ist da los?
Beste, beste, beste Killstreaks.
Das einzige Unterschied ist, dass ich da immer noch UIV bei.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das ist kaputt.
Die Anzeige ist eingefroren.
Das Spielen...
Ey, lass es mal 10.000 Spieler noch sein.
Das ist aber...
Quatsch, war weit.
5.000, 2.000 Spieler.
Das stimmt hinten und vorne nicht.
Beste, Black Ops 1 ist mein Lieblingsspiel.
Also mein Lieblings Call of Duty Spiel.
Without further ado, let's get right into the video.
Alright, boys, we're gonna use the AK-47.
Firing range.
We're gonna get a nice OG map firing range.
I don't know if you guys have realized, but I did get a...
Als die Maps noch halbwegs getaugt haben, ey.
Built it for my mic, oh gosh.
So if you guys do still hear popping, let me know and I'll try to adjust this a little
bit.
I know Black Ops 1 is a little less populated.
What the...
Bro.
Oh no, not again.
Oh, es leckt.
Es leckt.
Ach du Scheiße.
Bunker.
Könnte ich auch mal wieder spielen.
Was macht der da unten?
Ah, da wollen sie einen Chopper setzen, ne?
Mein Problem ist, ich kann mit dem Controller nicht mehr richtig spielen.
Ich hab's total verlernt.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt machen könnte, ist, ich könnte quasi, in Anführungsstrichen,
cheaten und meinen Maustastaturadapter verwenden für die Konsole.
Nicht, dass es so großartig was machen würde bei so einem alten Game.
Maus an die Xbox One, ne, das funktioniert ja nicht.
Du kannst doch nicht, du kannst mit der Maus an die Xbox One nicht alte Xbox 360 Spiele
spielen, die für Controller gedacht sind.
Aber ich hab mir ja vor einer Weile so einen Adapter gekauft, dass man auf der Konsole
auch mit Maus und Tastatur spielen kann.
Das ist halt quasi schon gecheatet, mehr oder weniger.
Alex sagt, ich hab nie verstanden, warum Shooter auf den Konsolen gespielt werden.
Eine der Hauptgründe ist, weil es eine viel, viel, viel größere Player Base hat als
auf dem PC.
Oh, beste.
Das ist dieser Bomber, der durch die komplette Map geht.
Vortex-OMG, was hast du für einen Adapter?
Vermaß, das ist aber nicht die original Rote-Tiger-Schreifen-Elotrix-Vermaß.
Der Gegner hat schon ein Blackbird am Start.
Die Gegner sind komplett am laggen.
Er move nicht, er steht einfach rum.
Der Zombie-Modus war cool.
Wisst ihr, was das Beste am Zombie-Modus war in Black Ops 1?
Ist das hier... das da, beste.
Beste hier.
Das war das Beste an ganz Black Ops Zombies.
Falls sich noch die ein oder andere dran erinnern.
Nicht schlecht.
Na gut, genug.
Aber die Black Ops 1-Zombie-Musik war beste.
Das war das in Black Ops 1.
Das ging mir auch immer auf den Sack, dass die Waffen so extrem, wie heißt das, gefinscht, gepinscht, gepinscht, gewackelt haben, wenn man hitpuncht wurde.
Das war das Beste an Black Ops 1.
Die Gegner...
Jawoll.
Der hat den Napalmstrike auf den Kopf gemacht gerade, oder?
Dann stirbt er.
Ach nee, hier geht es nicht durch die Decke.
Der Gegner aller, was ist mit dem los?
Der ist einfach nur AFK in-game.
Nee, du hast dich getroffen.
Die Commander Krieger Wauzis.
Das war schon ein bisschen cringe.
Oh, da kommt er durch den Tunnel.
Da ist noch einer im Tunnel drin, Alter.
Loserstrike.
Die Granate hätte ihn gleich noch gekillt.
Also für seine Verhältnisse klingt er echt motiviert.
Oh, was ist das für eine Waffe?
Also, Akimbo Shotgun, das war übelster Crap.
Das ist übelster Müll gewesen.
Das ist ganz schön Glück.
Die Dinger sacken einfach nur.
Jetzt wird er bestimmt Host und basht alles weg.
Die Akimbo Revolver waren richtig Poggers.
Was machen die da oben denn?
Na, im Haus sitzen, was denn sonst?
Ach, stimmt, vom Bett konnte man ja das andere Haus schießen, stimmt.
Real Renax, das reit mal mit K und nicht mit C.
Wie sie einfach da rumstehen, oh, das war aber knapp.
Beste, beste.
Gleich Chopper-Gunner raus, gleich Chopper.
Hat er überhaupt einen Chopper-Gunner dabei?
Ah, okay. Ja, der Chopper-Gunner war aber auch okay.
Hinten im Spawn, habt ihr es gesehen, im Spawn stand einer und hat es nicht gecheckt.
Der Typ, der stand halt schon die ganze Zeit da unten.
Sie sind komplett AFK-Gegner.
Ich fand das übelst nice, das Gunship.
Ich glaube, konnte man mit dem Gunship nicht auch teilweise ein bisschen durch Wände schießen?
Wie, könnt ihr verlieren das? Wie geht denn sowas?
Wie geht denn sowas, wie kann man die Runde verlieren?
Wie kann man die Runde verlieren?
Wie, Array, Array, Alter, das war so ein Scheiß-Map gewesen.
Also so heute die Standard-Map quasi.
What, was war das?
Galil, Silence-Galil, Beste.
Jetzt schreckt, schön hintereinander gerannt.
Oh, da sind alle gespawnt drin, links ist auch noch einer gespawnt.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Wo ist sich da der das sagt? Passt so zu gut.
Da liegt er einfach.
Die Auflösung war halt schon echt schlecht in dem Game.
Du erkennst ja über Range fast gar nichts.
Na klar liefen die, oh ne, Last Stand.
Fuck you Last Stand.
Der sollte auf jeden Fall in dem Game drinnen bleiben, weil der nächste Lobby ist der Host und Host-Vorteil in Black Ops 1 war der Shitter.
Fuck.
So, Chat, mal gucken ob es noch.
Max, was sagst du zu Warcraft 3 Reforged?
Männer, was, Männer, eben Klo verstoppt, welche Programmiersprache nutze ich um das zu beheben? Brainfuck würde ich sagen.
Der Bauer köpft den neue Intel CPU. Echt? Wo ist der Auer?
Der Auer, da ist er. Wo wird geköpft?
Da, Pock.
Hallo zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Es geht weiter mit dem Thema Z490 und dem 10900K. Im heutigen Video köpfen wir die CPU.
Die CPU ist hier schon drin. Ein 10900K Retail, der ist gerade auf dem Maximus 12 Extreme hier mit einer 360er Custom-Wasser-Kühlung drauf.
Wir gehen jetzt gleich erstmal ins Windows rein, schauen uns die Stock-Kühlungstemperaturen an bzw. Stock-Kühlungstemperaturen.
Die CPU übertaktet auf 5,1 GHz. Mehr geht bei dieser CPU nicht.
Außer wir gehen auf 1,4 Volt und da wird die CPU so unfassbar warm, dass es eigentlich nicht mehr vertretbar ist.
Deswegen bleibt die CPU bei 5,1 GHz, ca. 1,33 Volt.
Wir schauen, was passiert, wenn wir die Köpfen, ob wir die Temperatur verbessern können und vergleichen dann auch diese CPU mit der 8., 9. und dann eben mit der 10. Generation.
Was hat sich geändert? Die Größe, die dicke Heatswettergröße usw.
Das schauen wir uns am Ende an, wenn wir wissen, was unter dieser CPU bzw. unter dem Heatswetter ist.
Ich selber weiß das auch noch nicht. Ich habe zwar schon mal mitgesehen von einer geköpften CPU.
Ich weiß natürlich, dass sie verlötet ist. Das ist ja schon lange bestätigt.
Aber wenn die verlötet ist, wird das mit dem Köpfen doch eigentlich total sinnlos, oder?
Ok, hauptsache man möchte, wenn man gucken will, was drunter ist, ok.
Aber ich habe selbst noch keine CPU von dieser Generation geköpft.
Und damit würde ich sagen, legen wir los.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt vom neuen ASUS LG M2.
Insgesamt in der Oberreihe von 1,1 GHz übertaktet, also hier One Core Ratio Limit auf 51 bei allen Kern.
Dann habe ich den Cache Takt auf 48 gestellt, also haben wir 4,8 GHz.
Das Einzige, was Intel aktuell halt zu bieten hat, ist tatsächlich noch die etwas bessere Gaming Performance.
Das ist aber oft fast alles.
Ich meine, wann hatten wir zuletzt die Zeiten, wo es Intel versucht hat, über den Preis zu machen?
Und das ist ja aktuell so.
Man nennt, wir haben eine dauerhafte CPU Kernspannung von 1,33 Volt, RAM Spannung auf 1,45.
Und dann bei DigiPlus VRM haben wir Loadline Calibration Level 7, Köln Capability 140%.
Das ist alles und so schnell ist die CPU auch schon auf 5,1 GHz getaktet.
Viel mehr gibt es da nicht. Alles sehr, sehr ähnlich.
5,1? Das heißt, hat meiner auch.
Maximal, aber aktuell nicht.
Maximal ging bei mir auch 5,1, immer mit 8700K.
1900K.
Aber dann wurde das Ding schon echt warm.
Kühltechnisch hier hinten eben.
Mit Luft, Luft, Luftkühlung, wohlgemerkt.
60er Radiator mit der EK-Pumpe oben drauf. Die Lüfter laufen so bei etwa mittlerer Geschwindigkeit.
Also nicht die maximal mögliche Kühlung, aber realistisch gesehen zu dem, was man eben selbst verwenden würde.
Hier das schöne Maximus 12 Xtreme Mainboard.
Ist so gut, wie die gleiche CPU nur mit dem Erkern.
Ja, Intel kriegt ja auch seit letztem Jahr oder so, letzten zwei Jahren, drei Jahren, nichts Großartiges.
Da neues mehr gebacken gerade, habe ich den Eindruck.
Den EK-Block drauf, nichts wirklich besonderes und da würde ich jetzt sagen, lassen wir mal eben den R20 laufen.
Köpft mal!
Wir sehen, die CPU-Kernspannung droppt auf circa 1,31 Volt und der Last runter.
Temperaturtechnisch befinden wir uns so bei den mittleren 80er.
Monka meldt.
Cinebench-Score 6600 Punkte.
Ich will sehen, wie es geköpft wird.
Der kälteste Core lag hier bei 79.
Und der kälteste und der wärmste kälteste die meisten, aber so um die 85 Grad Celsius, wenn ich das gerade so sehen kann.
Da haben wir das Schmuckstück jetzt auf dem Tisch.
Ihr seht, daneben sind noch zwei andere CPUs.
Die habe ich schon geköpft.
Die waren auch schon länger geköpft und habe ich gestern noch vermessen.
Das sind 8700K.
Ah!
Ja, ja, ja.
Die habe ich, einzige CPU, die ich bisher selbst geköpft habe.
Und wo es gleich auf Anip funktioniert hat, 8700K.
Ich habe es schon auf dem Stream gezählt.
Ich habe echt geschwitzt.
Wenn du bei einer 400 Euro CPU da sitzt, die nicht lieferbar ist und du komplett neuen Rechner gebaut hast,
der nur mit dieser CPU funktioniert und ein halbes Jahr warten muss, bis die CPU wieder lieferbar ist und du köpfst die CPU.
Ich sage euch, man schwitzt.
Man schwitzt echt.
Und vor allem, weil die CPU anfängt, komische Knackgeräusche zu machen beim Köpfen.
Man zeigt es ja gleich.
Man spannt die ja ein und dreht die dann so.
Und beim Drehen macht eine CPU halt Knackgeräusche.
Und man ist es halt nicht gewöhnt, dass CPUs knackt.
Ja.
Wofür köpft man die?
Dass man Wärmeleit, äh, dass man Flüssigmetall oder halt ordentliche Wärmeleit passt oder besser.
Besser halt Flüssigmetall als Wärmeleitmittel dazwischen macht, dass der Kontakt zwischen CPU und Heatspreader besser ist
und die CPU deutlich kühler bleibt.
20-25 Grad kühler beim 8700K.
Bei den neuen ist das nicht mehr so wild.
7700K CPUs, das vergleichen wir aber gleich.
Wenn wir den geöffnet haben, das Ganze sollte relativ problemlos mit dem Delly DieMate 2 funktionieren.
Aufbau sollte ja quasi identisch sein zum 9900K.
Was jetzt?
Würde ich sagen, wir legen den ein und legen direkt los.
What?
Mein Sound qualkt gerade kurz weg, Leute.
Wonka?
War bei euch auch kurz das Sound weg?
Nee?
Wartet mal.
Windows, habt ihr den USB-Sound gehört?
Ich hab nämlich gerade den USB-Sound gehört.
Nee?
Dann liegt es an meinem zweiten Rechner.
Nee, dann liegt es an meinem zweiten Rechner, der komische Dinger macht.
Ich muss jetzt mal checken, nicht dass der wieder mein Audioformat umgestellt hat.
Hört sich gut an.
Hört sich kaputt an.
Okay, dann ist alles gut, dann stimmt's.
Los, dann legen wir die CPU mal ein.
Wieder mit dem Dreieck zum Dreieck.
Jetzt wird geköpft.
Das sollte eigentlich alles gleich geblieben sein.
Schnipp, schnapp, Köpfe ab.
Ich hatte ein anderes D-Lit-CPU-Köpftool.
Ich hatte eins, das hat die CPU gedreht.
Es gibt ja zwei.
Das Bauer-Tool war nicht verfügbar, als ich das machen wollte.
Aber von der Idee her funktioniert es genauso.
Die CPU knarrt dann so komisch.
Das hört sich echt nicht gut an für jemanden, der das noch nie gemacht hat.
Du denkst wirklich, du machst die CPU kaputt.
Okay, lässt sich noch nicht lösen.
Es ist zwar verschoben, aber ich kann die noch nicht ablösen.
Was bringt das Kopf jetzt mit verlöteten CPUs eigentlich gar nichts mehr?
Früher war das bei Intel-CPUs so, die haben Wärmeleitpaste zwischen den Heatspreader und der CPU in drinnen gemacht.
Die hat schlecht geleitet.
Dann hast du das aufgemacht und Flüssigmetall dazwischen gesprüht, aufgepinselt.
Das war eine deutlich bessere Verbindung zwischen CPU und Heatspreader, als das, was bei Intel standardmäßig drin war.
Die CPU ist halt viel kühler geblieben, 20 Grad.
Kommen wir einfach in die andere Richtung zurück.
Heute machen die das immer mit Flüssigmetall.
Nein, heute ist es einfach verlötet.
Da ist kein flüssiges Metall, sondern sie sind einfach zusammen.
So, die CPU ist geköpft.
Auf den ersten Blick sieht mir das einfach so aus, als wäre es ein 9900K mit einem etwas längeren Die.
Das sollte natürlich ein Druckschluss sein.
Eigentlich sollte der Die ja dünner sein.
Das werden wir aber gleich ausmessen.
Auf den ersten Blick ist auch die Kleberschicht an der Seite deutlich dicker.
Also das, was hier außen rum ist.
Das sieht aber nicht wie verlötet aus, oder?
Verlötet kannst du nicht so einfach abmachen bei der Größe.
Sind die vielleicht doch nicht verlötet?
Doch.
Aber wenn das verlötet wäre, das kannst du doch nicht einfach so abschieben.
Das sieht aus wie Paste, was aufeinander klebt.
Was man hier auch beim Hitzwetter sieht, das sieht dicker aus.
Weichrot, aha.
Ah, exellent.
Das ist das, was wir bisher bei den vorherigen CPUs hatten.
Bevor wir dann gleich flüssigen Metall auf die CPU auftragen können, müssen wir erstmal den Kleber abkratzen.
Das machen wir wie gewohnt mit einem Stück Kunststoff und dann vorsichtig mit dem Messer das Indium vom Chip abkratzen.
Mir ist klar, dass du ziemliche Kräfte damit aufwenden kannst, aber wenn das wirklich...
Ich habe jetzt halt dran gedacht, das ist wie wenn ich jetzt zwei Drähte miteinander verlöte.
Oder zwei Stückchen Draht nehme und verlöte.
Die Dinger sind so hart, du reißt eher den Draht ab, als dass du die Lötstelle aufkriegst.
Und da hätte ich halt gedacht, du machst eher die CPU kaputt, als dass du es aufkriegst.
Hatte irgendwas unter der CPU, um die Pins zu schützen?
Die haben doch keine Pins.
Die haben doch nur diese Auflage-Dinger.
Diese Pads.
Übrigens, da habe ich auch geschwitzt beim Abkratzen von diesem Silikon.
Ich habe das mit einer Kreditkarte gemacht und da habe ich mit Alkohol und einer Kreditkarte...
Ich habe bestimmt 45 Minuten geschrubbt und hatte immer permanent Schiss, dass ich das kaputt mache.
Üblich, wenn man das macht, wirklich wichtig aufpassen, dass man immer von innen nach außen über die Ecken geht.
Das kann schnell kaputt gehen.
Ansonsten brechen die weg und dann kann eure CPU schnell defekt sein.
Ja, so ein Zwischenstück zwischen Fingernägel und Kreditkarte war das.
Muss sagen, das hätte ich auch mit einer Rasierklemme machen sollen an der Seite.
Es geht viel einfacher.
Ich habe mittlerweile alles analysiert, die CPUs komplett vermessen und würde sagen,
wir schauen uns jetzt mal kurz die Unterschiede zwischen der 8. und 9. und 10. Generation an.
Wir starten mit diesem Bild.
Da seht ihr links 8700K, in der Mitte der 9900K, ganz rechts den 10900K.
Zur Orientierung sind alle CPUs so angeordnet, dass das Dreieck nach links unten zeigt.
Der größte Unterschied, den man feststellen kann, ist, dass bei der 8. und 9. Generation die Nasen oben sind.
Huge Änderung, Intel.
Das macht die CPU gleich 300% schneller, dass die Nasen unten statt so oben sind.
Wir haben ca. 4,3 Gramm bei 8700K, 5,4 Gramm bei 9900K und ca. 5,4 Gramm bei 10900K.
Also 9900K, 10900K, ungefähr gleich schwer.
Wenn wir die Die Größen vergleichen, sehen wir alle drei CPUs haben die gleiche Die Breite von 9,2 mm.
Der 8700K hat eine Länge von 16,7 mm, 9900K 19,6 mm, 10900K 22,4 mm.
Man kann da sagen, der 10900K ist ca. 10% länger als ein 9900K.
Der einzige Grund, warum die Nasen anders sind, ist, dass man ein neues Mainboard braucht.
Ausrechnen haben wir 153 mm² bei 8700K, 180 mm² bei 9900K, 206 mm² bei 10900K.
Das ganze von der Seite betrachten, um die Platinenhöhe zu betrachten.
Die hatten alle schon eine sehr dünne Platine von nur 0,87 mm.
Der 9900K hatte wieder eine dickere Platine, so wie früher schon der 4770K von 1,15 mm.
Und die gleiche Dicke hat auch wieder der 10900K, also 1,12 mm.
Der Chat ist im Weg, das ist jetzt für die eine Zahl hier.
Rechts steht 1,12 mm.
Platinenhöhe. Jetzt kommt der interessante Teil, und zwar die Die Höhe.
8700K hat ja einen sehr dünnen Die, genauso wie 6700K.
Was ist das Silberne eigentlich? Das ist eine gute Frage. Was ist denn das für ein Metall?
Weiß ich nicht.
Der Chat weiß sowas.
Zinn. Ob das Zinn ist? Zinn, okay.
Silizium. Nein, das ist kein Silizium.
Uran. Sehschott Big Brain Chat wieder am Start.
700K, 7700K, die hatten alle die gleiche Die Höhe.
Das Ganze wurde beim 9900K ja verdoppelt auf 0,88 mm.
Und der 10900K, ich hatte erst vermutet...
Chat.
Witz vorbei, Chat.
Komplett wieder zurück geht auf die gleiche Höhe wie beim 8700K auf 0,44 mm.
Aber man hat jetzt hier einen Mittelwert und ist bei 0,58 mm gelandet.
Dann noch einen kurzen Blick auf...
Ich kann das jetzt überhaupt nicht einschätzen. 0,58, ja, okay, zur Kenntnis genommen.
Zehnte Generation zum Vergleich.
Natürlich links sehen wir kein Gold unten aufgetragen, weil diese CPU noch nicht verlötet war.
Kein Gold.
Dementsprechend sehen wir die goldene Schicht unten, was notwendig ist, damit das Indium eben gut haftet.
Indium. Indium ist es, Leute. Indium.
Dass da eine Ecke so ein bisschen abgeflacht ist, da haben wir so einen 45°-Winkel.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der irgendeinen technischen Hintergrund hat.
Gefühlt ist es einfach so, dass sich alle CPUs irgendwie mechanisch so minimal voneinander unterscheiden,
aber einen wirklichen technischen Hintergrund kann ich da nicht feststellen, warum dem so ist.
Wenn wir das Gewicht vergleichen...
Stimmt, Ende hat Recht.
Ende hat Recht, Indium ist das, was zum Löten verwendet wird, aber nicht die Sachen, die zusammengelötet werden.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Heatspreader 26,6 Gramm, 9900K war dann schon deutlich leichter.
Eigentlich einfach nur, weil er dünner ist.
20,2 Gramm, 10900K ist dann dementsprechend ein bisschen dicker.
Ist das für irgendetwas irgendwie relevant, wie viel Gramm der Heatspreader hat?
Ich meine, who cares, oder?
... geworden und lande dadurch auch bei 22,2 Gramm.
Wenn wir die Höhe des Heatspreaders im mittleren Punkt messen, dann sehen wir auch,
der 8700K Heatspreader war am dicksten, mit 3,11 Millimeter, dann 9900K, 2,35 Millimeter in der Mitte
und der 10900K Heatspreader 2,59 Millimeter in der Mitte.
Natürlich ist die Gesamt-CPU-Höhe immer die gleiche, weil wir den gleichen Grundsockel haben,
also die gleiche Sockelgröße, dementsprechend wird, wenn der Dye dünner oder dicker wird, dann auch der Heatspreader passend eingefasst.
Ah, die Bauer-Cut.
Hallo.
Damit können wir bestätigen, was uns in der initialen Präsentation gesagt hatte, dass der Dye eben etwas dünner geworden ist,
was zu besseren Temperaturen führen sollte, weil, wie schon beim 9900K Review erwähnt,
Silicium hat eine schlechtere Wärmeleitfähigkeit als...
Das ist der besten Harim Heatspreader.
...Kupfer, dementsprechend, wenn Silicium dünner gehalten wird und dann schneller quasi, sage ich mal,
das Kupfer kommt vom Heatspreader, dann sollten die Temperaturen minimal besser sein.
Wir haben jetzt hier einen Unterschied von 0,3 Millimeter, das wird nicht so krass viel bringen,
wir wissen ja vom 9900K, wenn wir den ein bisschen runterschleifen um 0,2-0,3 Millimeter,
dann bringt uns das um die 3-4 Grad...
Du kannst fast einen eigenen Studiengang machen.
Also die Temperaturen werden jetzt nicht mega krass plötzlich besser sein,
sondern man wird so 3-4 Grad bessere Temperaturen haben als gegen einen 9900K,
wenn man das jetzt vergleichen würde.
Übrigens, die Lötschichtdicke von dem, was ich messen konnte, hat ungefähr 0,3 Millimeter,
das ist auch der Grund, warum Flüssigmetall in der Theorie besser sein sollte, weil Flüssigmetall...
Okay, was kommt denn am Ende raus?
Sonst ist jetzt alles fertig, das Mainboard ist genau aufgeschrieben,
hier links in der Spalte seht ihr die Maximaltemperaturen aus dem aktuellen Run
und hier dahinter dann die Temperaturdifferenz.
Der Core 1 hier ist 5 Grad kühler geworden, das ist der kleinste.
Okay, anscheinend ist das Material von Intel kacke.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es überhaupt irgendwas bringt.
Und hier beim Core 6 haben wir glatte 10 Grad, das ist echt sogar...
Krass, das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Der größere Unterschied, als ich dachte, ich bin eigentlich eher so von...
Hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
...6 bis maximal 7 Grad Celsius verbessert.
Ich hätte eher gedacht, es war überhaupt kein Unterschied.
...ausgegangen, was man eher so normalerweise sieht bisher,
aus der Erfahrung von Köpfen von Intel CPUs.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen zur Sicherheit noch mal einen zweiten Run,
den ich erwarten würde.
Aber heftig, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Also das war natürlich relativ schnell nach dem...
Nee, bei AMD ist kaum ein Unterschied.
Im Schnitt würde ich sagen, wenn ich das mal so grob überfliege,
bei den Temperaturen, wenn wir Flüssigmetall verwenden,
wie erwartet, um die 7 bis 8 Grad Celsius...
Ja, okay, Pongas. Hätte ich echt nicht gedacht.
Wirklich nicht.
Leute, ich müsste jetzt eigentlich was essen gehen.
Wir können...
Der Hacker dauert 30 Minuten.
Leute, wisst ihr, was wir machen?
Wir gucken jetzt noch hier den krassen Wim-Hacker uns an.
Und ich hole mir mal kurz was zu futtern.
Und ich esse was dabei.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
So, wieder da.
Das wird jetzt wahnsinnig, supergesundes Essen.
mit ein bisschen Tomatensauce
und massig Parmesan-Käse dabei
den Parmesan-Käse brauche ich dabei
dass es überhaupt nach was schmeckt
huge gesund
und wir gucken mal, ich sehe hier den
der Typ ist echt, also geschwindigkeitsmäßig
er ist natürlich übelst heftig
gucken, wenn es los geht
mal gucken, wenn es los geht
oh ne, es geht schon los, fuck
ah, 22 Sekunden
ihr müsst mal gucken, wie schnell
der tippt
so, Parmesan-Käse
beste
exellent
sind das Chinesen?
ne, ich glaube
ich hab letztens mal scoreboard geguckt
und ein paar Videos
ich glaube
einer der besten ist glaube ich in Weißrosse
oder so
oder aus Ukraine
ich krieg es gerade nicht richtig zusammen
aber es gibt Leute, die sind deutlich krasser
und er sagt ja auch selbst, er ist nur schnell
nur, nur in Anführung, nur schnell
Käse fertig gerieben
aus der Packung
so
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht ab
erstmal Wim aufmachen
und den
den Hacker-Modo starten
what?
was jetzt?
Zeit überlastet, Monka ist
zu viele Hexer am Hackhorn
guck mal, du hast 3 Stunden Zeit
für alle Challenges
und er ist fertig nach 20 Minuten oder so
so schnell, wie der den Kram macht
hätte ich die Frage nicht mal gelesen
es geht voll ab
alles klar
ich sollte nur von Index starten
K-1
also I plus 1-J
also A plus I plus 1-J
es hat wieder abgeht, ich hab keine Ahnung, was er überhaupt macht
der einzige, das voll beruhigend findet, wenn man Leute tippen hört, ich könnte dabei einpennen
im Nachhinein versteht er wahrscheinlich selbst nicht mehr, was er da programmiert hat, aber es funktioniert
alles klar, fertig
erste Aufgabe durch easy
was?
wie sieht er das?
so schnell
ich hab den Intro Text noch nicht mal gelesen
wahrscheinlich ist das auch gerade der Trick
der liest, der guckt sich einfach die Tests an
und checkt, was die wollen anstatt zu lesen
was die wollen und dann die Tests damit zu machen
ja klar
Demopan, der hat schon
hunderte Aufgaben davon gemacht
klar, natürlich, es ist alles Übungssache
cool, richtig nice
ich weiß nicht, ob das passen wird
also ich muss sagen, bisschen viel Nudeln mit bisschen wenig Tomatensauce und viel zu viel Parmesan
ok, nachdem ich die Frage erst gar nicht verstanden habe, bzw. nicht mal die ersten drei Sätze der Frage lesen konnte
wo er jetzt schon bei den Test Cases ist, habe ich keine Ahnung, was er macht
aber er weiß schon
und ich außerdem am Essen bin
ich glaube, die Aufgaben in diesen
in diesen
Competitions, wo es um schnell sein geht
die Aufgaben sind gar nicht mal so schwer
aber was es halt schwierig macht, ist das irgendwie 30 Sekunden hinzukriegen
ich hab sowas noch nie probiert
ich wollte mal ein paar Einsteiger-Sachen im Stream machen
wow, jetzt geht er wieder ab
was mich hier abschreckt, ist, dass die alle C++ programmieren
ne, die müssen nicht in C++, aber es hat seine Vorteile
diese Competitive Challenges in C++ zu machen
erstens hast du oftmals die Sache, dass die Aufgaben nur gewisse Zeit brauchen dürfen, bis sie durch sind
und C++ ist halt eine gute Kombination aus Geschwindigkeit und recht umfangreicher Standard Library
und du kannst in C++, und das ist für diese Sachen halt auch wirklich von Vorteil
man kann in C++ halt auch sehr kurz, sehr eklig schnell Dinge machen
also ich verstehe, warum ich C++ verwende
man kann auch C-Sharp auswählen, aber C-Sharp ist dafür nicht gut geeignet
C-Sharp hat so viel Boilerblade, teilweise drum herum, dass es in C++ doch deutlich schöner ist
und außerdem muss man sagen, C-Sharp ohne eine ordentliche IDE ist auch eklig
also sowas hier rein C-Sharp im Wim runter tippen, könne ich gar nicht
sorry, C-Raute meine ich natürlich
oder C, wie hat unser Azubi mal gesagt, C-Lattenzaun
ich frage mich, wenn man ihn später fragt, so was hast du dir dabei gedacht, ja keine Ahnung, einfach runter geschrieben und es hat funktioniert
er macht ja meistens noch Erklärungsvideos
easykiller fragt, wo ist die Code Dokumentation
in dem Fall ist das nicht nötig, weil wir wissen alle, dass guter Code sich selbst dokumentiert
und wer das nicht versteht, ja dann
wer so gute Variablen Namen hat wie N, M, T, I, C, S, J, ist doch top
herz93 sagt, aber so kann er nicht richtig programmieren, sondern eher nur Lösungen für die Aufgaben machen
holy brains ist am Start, exellent
ich copypaste das jetzt rein und es funktioniert instantly
wo ist Y, äh J deklariert, ähm da
jetzt wäre die Corona App schon lange fertig
der hat gesagt, was ihr wollt eine Corona App, Moment Leute wir machen das mal schnell
so Corona App jetzt brauche ich noch ein Mobilfunkgerät zum testen, fertig
bei ihm hätte es in der Corona App auch kein Problem gegeben, dass die Corona App keine gendergerechte Aussprache hätte
dort gäbe es sowas gar nicht, da würden die Leute einfach I und Y heißen
weil jeglicher Text eindeutig zu bloated ist
was über einen Buchstabe rausgeht ist zu bloated
wie kann man denn ins Programmieren reinkommen, ich finde das unglaublich interessant
besonders Steuerung von Mechatronik selbst zu machen, aber womit soll man anfangen
wenn du ein Problem vor Augen hast, dann ist am besten sich dazu was zu suchen
mit dem du das Problem lösen kannst
also zum Beispiel wenn dich Microcontroller Zeug interessiert, kann ich dir nur empfehlen
geh auf Amazon, hol dir einen ESP32 Board, so eins hier
zum Beispiel, weil da hast du den Vorteil, da ist schon alles dran
sprich du hast dir eine CPU drauf, du hast deine GPIO Pins drauf, holst dir so ein Board
und dann fängst du einfach an mit Platform.io und der Arduino IDE
ich würde dir Platform.io empfehlen, da ist nämlich im ESP32 schon alles drin
installierst du dir das einfach, hast eine fertige IDE, stöpsel per USB, dann ESP32 dran
und fängst einfach mal an, ein bisschen rumzubasteln, ist nicht so schwierig
es gibt vor allem für Arduino und ESP32 Gerichte sau viele Tutorials und fertige Sachen
also wenn dich so Microcontroller Steuerung interessiert, kann ich dir das nur empfehlen
hol dir entweder ein Arduino, aber ich würde eher sagen, hol dir ein ESP32
und nimm dir Platform.io und leg los, gibt es zig Tutorials, ist auch wirklich nicht schwer
haben wir auch letztens hier im Stream gemacht, für eine Steuerung von meiner Klingel
ach ja und weiter, ich habe keine Ahnung was er da macht, ich lasse das nur gerade laufen
weil ich es echt geil finde, wie schnell der ist und weil ich gerade am essen bin
ah ja klar, wenn V nicht U ist, ist ja logisch, wer hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass V nicht U sein kann
das ist ja mal ein Big Brain Vergleich, das ist ein XOR, oder?
das ist ein XOR, wenn VXOR nicht, wenn was ungleich 0 rauskommt, excellent
das ist zwar was, man hätte wahrscheinlich auch einfach schreiben können, in dem Fall V ungleich U
aber das ist kürzer, ob er davor wohl ein Struktogramm angelegt hat, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich darauf sagen soll
Struktogramm, UML-Diagramm hat er bestimmt gemacht
Bad, gleich 1, ah da oben ist Bad, guckt
ich wurde mal, ich weiß nicht ob ihr es gehört habt, ich wurde mal von einem Grill übelst angeschissen
wahrscheinlich weil das genervt hat, weil ich das immer gemacht habe, dass ich nicht so fest mit der Gabel
beim Essen aufpicken in den Teller machen soll, das würde nerven, Leute Chat was sagt ihr, nervt das?
also wenn ich jetzt zu Nudel hier auf die Gabel mache, dann ich neige dazu mit der Gabel zu fest auf den
Teller, einige Leute sind das sehr anfällig, ja ich weiß
aber ich muss überlegen was da los
Guck hier, das meine ich, es gibt Memory und Time Limits, deswegen ist C++ auch sehr beliebt
C++ ist halt ne richtig gute Sprache wenn es darum geht, dass das relativ wenig Speicher braucht, relativ schnell ist und ne umfangreiche Standard Library hat
ich verstehe warum die alle C++ verwenden oder C verwenden in dem Fall, C bzw. C++ Verwendung
warum macht er nicht einfach eine Elektron App mit Javascript, easy, da, du könnt die App vielleicht mit einem Gigabyte RAM gestartet kriegen
ja das ist übrigens der C, wenn ein Editor zeigt, muss ich mal was sagen kurz zu
ja, das da oben ist glaube ich ne Sache, die geht bloß in GCC, kann sein, dass ich misserzähle, dass Microsoft auch kann
und hier das, included glaube ich die ganze Standard Library, bitsstdc oder, ich glaube das ist so ein Special Header, der included glaube ich die ganze Standard Library
das ist, dass man nicht so viele includes machen muss, das sind die Competitive Programming Hacks
aber er benutzt doch Windows, naja klar, aber der kann trotzdem GCC verwenden, das ist eindeutig C++ ja
ich bin immer wieder begeistert, wie der da selbst noch durchblickt
er benutzt wirklich Wim, ja und wie ey, das coole bei ihm finde ich, er benutzt Wim fast wie einen ganz normalen Editor
er benutzt recht wenig Wim Special Sachen irgendwie, wahrscheinlich weil er selten was ändern muss, weil es einfach immer direkt funktioniert
aber er ist trotzdem sau schnell, ey das ist so schwierig zu lesen
also sprich, nimmt er den größeren Value, wenn das größer ist, nimmt er das, wenn das größer ist, nimmt er das, dann rechnet er das zu S dazu
was bekommt der Gewinner von der Coding Challenge, ich vermute mal, dass es bei Google Sache ist, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es sogar ein bisschen Preisgeld gibt
aber du bekommst Punkte, dass du dann im Leaderboard irgendwo oben stehst, weiter oben stehst
die ganzen Hexer-Competitions haben ja alle Punkte, die man bekommt, dass man quasi im Leaderboard sieht, wer die krassen Hexer sind
guck, das mein ich, der hat grad einfach die Sache gelöscht, anstatt groß D zu drücken, wie man das in Wim machen kann, aber er ist trotzdem sau schnell, der braucht das einfach gar nicht
ich könnte wetten, da macht die Einrückung auch von Hand
was er wohl für eine Tastatur benutzt, bestimmt so ein alles riesengroßes IBM Keyboard oder so
ich glaube, entweder er hat das mal gezeigt oder man hat es in dem Fragenbeantworter Stream-Markt gesehen, können wir nachher mal gucken
also ehrlich Leute, mal angenommen, ich müsste, ich würde einen Pull-Request bekommen, also ich bin für keine C++ Anwendung zuständig
mal angenommen, ich würde einen Pull-Request bekommen, wo ich so Codesubmitted kriege, da würde ich wahrscheinlich, den würde ich merchen und einfach nur Fivehead drunter kopieren
einfach weil es, ich würde mir gar nicht die Mühe geben, das zu verstehen gerade, das ist wirklich echt hochgradig kryptisch
ich mein, man versteht es schon, das ist ja relativ kurz, aber es macht es dadurch, dass er halt alles auf die kürzeste Art und Weise schreibt, vor allem nicht ungleich, sondern auch x-Ohr und, äh, es ist wirklich, es macht es echt schwierig zu lesen
aber das coole ist, das muss ja auch nicht lesbar sein, es muss einfach nur schnell sein in dem Fall, also nicht ausführspeechsmäßig, sondern schnell erstellt
deswegen verwendet man ja auch nur Variablen und auch wenn die Typdefinitionen sind zu lang, der schreibt auch LL und AR anstatt Array und sowas, richtig optimist, big brain shit
A1 plus gleich C Array Index S1 plus T minus J mal J, ach ja, alles klar, logisch, logisch
aber was auch sonst, oder, also ich finde das spricht für sich selbst, wo wir da beim Thema sind, guter, klarer Code braucht keine Dokumentation, dokumentiert sich alles selbst
Sample Fill, what? What? What? What frage ich mich auch gerade, aber aus anderem Gründen wie er
ich finde es immer toll, dass in diesen Aufgaben, ist ja auch, ist ja auch wenn man sich beispielsweise in der IHK Prüfung die Aufgaben anguckt
da steht immer so eine Name drinne, da steht dann zum Beispiel drinne, sie sind Auszubildende in der Alligator GmbH und sowas
Ihr Ausbildungskollege Max fragt sie da und dazu, also die bringen da immer so Namen dazu rein, in dem Fall ist es Christobal
warum ist es wichtig, dass Christobal hier irgendein Problem hat, weil was ist Christobal für ein Name
das ist bestimmt einfach nur Fülltext, dass es mehr Rauschen hat für die Noobs quasi, das heißt man darf sich an solchen Sachen hier gar nicht aufhalten lassen
S1 plus T minus J, es wird immer klarer was er bastelt, komplett, komplett Obvious
Just to make sure it compiles, I remember they like, they give you a penalty for compiler, but then they don't give you a penalty for like filling the sample
Ok so back to this problem
RealRenac sagt ich habe absolut keine Ahnung was er macht, nachdem ich die Aufgaben nicht gelesen habe, ich gerade am essen bin, habe ich auch keinen Plastenschimmer was er macht
Aber er macht es gut, weil er gewinnt, hier sieht man mal wieder, die wahren Hacker Tools, OBS, OneNote, Wim, Windows Snipping Tool, so sehen die echten Hacker Tools aus
Und die Matrix als das Chrome Steam, habt ihr gehört, dass ein neuer Matrix Film rauskommen soll
Oh jetzt will er es wissen, ich habe ihn glaube ich noch nie in Struct anlegen sehen, jetzt wird es ernst Leute, jetzt wird es ernst
Aber ich hoffe das Struct heißt dann am Ende auch X oder so
Oh das stelle ich mir echt schwierig vor, der hat diese Aufgabe abgeschickt und hat gesagt testen und hat mit der nächsten Aufgabe angefangen
Also ich glaube wir sind da einfach zu low brain für, für ihn ist das kein Problem
Da macht einfach in der linken Gehirnhälfte das eine und in der rechten Gehirnhälfte das andere easy, um nicht zu sagen easy
Er denkt, brain multithreading
Ich glaube das ist einer der Menschen, der wirklich von einem Aluhut profitieren könnten
Jetzt nicht zur Schutz vor Strahlung, sondern zum Wärme ableiten
Das war schon ein Pains Champions
Übrigens 3 Stunden Time Limit, das sind 17 Minuten vorbei und er ist schon fast durch
Quasi ein Heatspreader genau, ein Headspreader
Das war ein guter Joke hier
App, was ist App?
Verstehe, der hat es schon verwendet bevor er es definiert hat
What is happening?
So, gleich fertig gefordert
Ich muss seine Bookmarks gucken
Ich weiß nicht was das ist
Das war der Fix auf den wir gewartet haben
Man merkt wenn es ernst wird, wenn er anfängt Structs zu verwenden und die Sachen mehr als ein Charakter lang sind, dann wird es ernst
Wer ist der Typ eigentlich?
William Lin
Wer weiß ich auch nicht
Zumindest gewinnt er Programmiercompetitions
Query ist ja auch klar
Seit wann darf man in Structs Methoden definieren? Ist das irgendein C++ Ding?
In Standard C kann es eigentlich nicht funktionieren
In Standard C gibt es keine Methoden
Ich habe gedacht es wäre etwas sinnvolles in C++
In C sharp ist es schon ziemlich unterschiedlich ob es eine Klasse oder ein Struct ist
Das ist eine gute Variable
Oh oh quasi
Klar geht das Flo96
So fertig essen
Ein bisschen Nachtisch und dann ist alles gut
Ein richtig nice Hacker
Der ist einfach so schnell
Ich lasse es einfach mal so stehen
Ich habe keine Ahnung was auch immer
Er meint euch Chat
Der wusste dass wir das gucken
Alter ist das hässlich ich checke an nichts
Aber es geht und das ist das wichtige
Was sagen die YouTube Kommentare unter seinem Video?
Das ist ein guter Grüßkorn
Geil, geil
Natürlich muss das A sein
Das ist ein guter Grüßkorn
Die ECMAS